[music]
here
yesterday in london started the final stage
series grand hour tour on the first game day
both semi-final parks ended in a draw
but the result does not reflect the intensity at all
struggle several times it seemed that
fabiano caruana close to winning first
a place in the world rankings but definitely a game
Hikaru Nakamura escaped
defeat
inventive game maxim your
kilogram got out of the dubious
situation against lebanon aronian and one
game behind and score in both semi-finals
equal to 33 how is it possible we will find out together
find out right now
[music]
good afternoon dear friends keep going
a series of our broadcasts from the final tournament
grand hour tour in london
will start in just a few minutes
the second games of the semi-finals, but I also
like this math tied
got three points so hard hard not
score high tournament points up to 1 kind
day good morning yes like addiction
where do you look from
we welcome you back on the air from
studios in st louis i before survey
next to me is my friend evgeny
Miroshnichenko had a lot of interesting things
yesterday during the first round I must say
that the draw death of chess is undeniable
maybe it will seem to someone that again
need to talk about it but yesterday there were two
very very much I would like some
I would not have anyone's before
properties are necessary and if we will be
continue to please and further also
chess player it will certainly be very
great
today another classic chess with
color change and tomorrow will be very
a lot of chess with at least six games
participants will play against each other then
have we will have 12 parties for sure and
maybe even a tiebreak though given
how many points and draws
tiebreak is mathematically not that likely
as it seemed
about how many points and finish more
let's talk let's remember that is it
the end of the year has almost passed
edge hour tour series let's see who
we had a table of general Assyria
crunchies tour as proper players
selected to london here you go
before the London tournament following the results
four stages, then this is what happened
situation hikaru nakamura ranked first
place in the general lights out yes and we see and by
credit points for prize money yes, too
the second from Lebanon previously needed only on the floor
as a result, Levon Aronian fell behind him
who has not won a single tournament
Komi division 1 single copy but played everywhere
very very reliable tight nowhere
took a place below 5 what actually
stability gives a lot
this series is even more than 1
good result for third place
Maximize your ogres who is very cool
played rapid chess and in general
did not take much risk of not being selected and
fourth place is the only
division in the table as you see 4 5 place
shared by points caruana
and in from the forest which is of course great
achievement for fabiano caruana who
started terribly completely in the series for
him two penultimate places in a row and not
only I think in the hospital, but he himself is already
did not strongly believe that he would accept participants and
Quite the contrary, everything developed if
which I played very well
remember we decided when i was before the start
single cab and one of the main in general
he has no favorites for selection
worked out for a start it did not work out
st louis pedan glitz
and then the essential hood is unhealthy and in
ended up in a tie-break in an interruption with
fabiana and lost to purana exactly fast
Shanda brought one and a half to the cavity so well
actually
people who took the first 4th place play at
us now in london
play in a very interesting way
which we discussed yesterday with Peter
they said that in general it would be nice
probably of this kind knockouts
spend yes and yes the whole idea of ​​the grand hour tour
about what is universal universal
rating up to need to be able to play everything
types of chess, that's it
the formula proper advances in this
year in history since the final and
tricks passes here according to the formula which
these two parties in front of your eyes
classics two parts rapid and four
games in blitz at the same time the price is the price of a point
again on your screen all three are different
format 6 points is played in each
classical parts
four points in each rapid game and two
points in each game of blitz and that we have
twenty eight points at stake
so to win the match you need
dial 15 dial this way or that
way you need to score 15 points but all
games will nevertheless be played even
if someone gets to 15 points yes here
I just wanted to say that well, we have
until at first it looks like someone
someone will go to smash and even if up to 15
points will be scored before the game is played
all games according to the schedule the match will continue
match work for well and again we
constantly
we remind you that control in general
recognizable but everywhere here is this letter
z small and words delay completely
for explanation in the description of the control in
classic gancha 100 is not played with
adding 30 seconds after each move
namely the delay test second
delay which means that if you
made a move in less than half a minute or
less than ten or 3 seconds
shortened control then time with you not
written off to accumulate it is impossible and
therefore, the color met and become tougher
than when playing with the addition again
we will be in this everyone to remind me
I'm sure it's to remember and our ours
regular viewers have already learned this speech
better than me but nevertheless not harmful about
this well, and a little reminder of the schedule
before the first game has been played 2 will
played today rapid awaits us tomorrow
blitz proper definition
who is going to play the final and who is playing
match for third place, let me remind you that
they will play the final and the match for the third
place is also not this is also very
I like this formula because
this provides us with constant two
parties two live parties, that is to say, which
you can switch and more always
better than less step
respectively between the semifinals we
final one day of rest and then there
final exactly the same
schedule for 1 mb of one batch in
classics and on December 17 on the last day
the entire rapid will be played, the entire blitz and
need a tie-break well and time
start
indicated main time indicated
then on which we go on the air we
have pity on us, but I will mention again from above
then that is for those who look at
Moscow time is 17:00 Moscow time
yes yes and respectively 14:00 GMT
what does it matter because
just try to GMT play on
neck part yes it says 3 times yes yes
for players for commentators for us
unfortunate until that must be here 8 am
and for you dear viewers I suspect
that most of us look that way
said from Russia yes he is oriented again
for Moscow time
well, don't forget
you can chat with commentators
support us somehow in social
networks nu pu pu hashtag grant hour turda in
basically it's youtube and twitch i'm so
I understand that there are already some
this correspondence
goes about it and again before
Eugene has a computer on which
open open clearly taxes and you so
what if there are questions in particular
towards the end of the tour when a little
released temporarily but talk to
a spectator and always with joy dear
answer questions yes, well, what about white
today he plays in the return, so to speak, in
second leg Hikaru Nakamura vs.
fabiano caruana look at the profile
hikaru nakamura here you go first
place in selection
Grange From Tour Very Confident To 2
the only participant won two
wins in tournaments
4 there's the very first tournament there
an interesting episode happened because
very close he was to the winner of the
forest and they both lost in the last
dowley but you're no less brilliant otherwise
you can’t name a game in a tournament with a shortened
control allowed him not to think at all
about the result, all hilkov, of course, everything
equally he wanted to the depths of home
territory is good to play everything as open and
did not work out, but even here is the division
last place not
don't knock it out and close and slaughter we
London and from first place came out first
the place goes hikaru nakamura yes and
look at the results of his opponent
fabiano caruana as i mentioned here is very
rapid chess was not easy to develop and
infusions in paris it was the penultimate
place then much better went gone
case in st louis well actually from
st louis selected fabian horror so
to say both costs and out as if with their own
base fourth place is given how would
two ninth place is obvious
improvement afterwards
division 1 3 in the 7th field cup
with lemon wounded by magnus carlsen
let him get into trouble
sense suite corner before tie-break
reminded
quite confidently won black mini not
experienced no problems and white brought out
nice party objectively so well
here are the stats
leads to the commune after all plus one yes
Well, it’s clear that these statistics have been years
five six seven when I'm not playing them
not quite as much as I don't want to offend
our graphic editors, but it does not
actually takes yesterday's game into account
draws already three kings and beggars already 30
they crossed started 4 dozen nefig
will start soon perhaps yes yes so well and
proper in the London Territory to
for the fifth year it turns out passes on
london chess classic tournament for
you be and more but 5 5 times they will
meet in this territory while it was
11 with two no step the score is equal but also to me
it seems like lately maybe
to say that the trend has changed and I think
if you take statistics for the last years
three then it will probably be a plus for my fame
feeling that pluses and kind of that that
nakamura stuffed
they never forget the initial plus
which we do not forget in the second semi-final
mature aronian vs your kilos there
yesterday Aronian was crushing somewhere with black
outplayed
let's see what he can do with white
Levon Aronian 2nd place in Grand Prix selection
hastura due to let's say so dense yes
you can't call them a super-successful night
tight result europe you me neither
one bad result after a good one
always the top half of the table and then
division 1 place in the very offset us so
the biggest tournament in the tournament
sen field cup yes classic than very
imaginative play gave you a memorable way
dana won in the last round
enchanting game alexander grischuk oni
unmistakable far but objectively one
of the most interesting parties why would they
played very cool yes the most brutal
the color of the note in which Sasha began to make mistakes
if any of you haven't seen this game
find
find look very very
curious harbor show yes well here
second left to ryan and his
adversary maxim your logs let's
let's see his third place
played a little more successfully in rapid that
allowed him to even take a seat in
middle of the standings in sep field
copy still get selected and lo and behold
maxim you can say that it seems to me neither
at one point there was no doubt that he
is taken from him
that is, nakamura came out mathematically before
start of the first round and if correct
remember the figure is the probability of exiting the case
final tournament four to start
synthol who was somewhere 95 percent he
definitely should have lost the game there
behind the party people needed the rest
the results had to add up somehow
in general, it was not enough for him to take the last
it was necessary that everything else
it worked out for him
catastrophically yes and he is completely
calmly
placed in the middle of the table and
selected in
but the score between them here we see the score
equal again I think in my opinion it is
here are the same statistics for yesterday's early
the morning before the game they played
draw yesterday but it's not so important
do not affect the balance yes i.e. 55 at 22
already it turns out not someone else's and on in London
finely tel da vinci 1
well, let's show it all the same
prize fund because because
nice to see what exactly
there is a struggle besides obviously prestige and and
title winner ganch side here behind
this week the next one will be played by 300
thousand dollars 120000 winner 80 for
second place and match for third place too
makes sense because we don't really
not 60 and 40
nissan in general is very worthy
the gangster prize money has always been and
always been very good in this sense
Tournament series toner yes well, you can start
probably talking about some intrigue
who will present us today such
love k again a little strange
this conversation looks like given that u
we are still ahead in every match except
classics at least 6 more games with
shortened control me but you can
probably remember that conversation
which was actively conducted, let's say we are on the air
censing they talked about it when they talked
about the world championship match
Carlson caravans to whom I am playing today
white
with a crown and here we see on on our
screen you end apparently ceremony
submission of the second day of withdrawal on
the second day in a row in the hall is huge
the number of children which is always nice
see and
the little man you see on
your screen with a microphone for many years
is an inspiration and
the organizer of the program cha son schools in
UK and
I think that in my own in many respects with this
and such is the composition of the viewer
elders audience line up tied with
him that the idea is being actively promoted
teaching chess in schools and
program it has already become international
here is another interview about me
only because this one is for hikaru
the young gentleman went barely e4 and
will leave the move to this instructor so
not always waiting not 4 not always before
hikaro and in this sense enough
universal matiz as well as everything
all here but here is the binary such
chagan and in general why offend a child
tell the child and 4 then don't go and 4
racing can get upset
in the crown I decided not to take no sin on
how sushi is and what is russian
the party is planned apparently on occasion
russian couple yes wonder than hikaru
are going to scare us, well, probably
going back to my conversation maybe
and not what yes, that's given exactly
That's exactly what I wanted to mention
hikaru must obviously consider himself
pretty serious minion no hijacking
must consider myself I think that many
finally
a serious favorite but first of all
probably in a blitz portion, but also perhaps
Europe is also Europe, even though they play
of course quite slow rapid
which in modern times
let's say that
world rapid championship
control 1510 they play 2510 before the spectrum
here it is of course such a slow rapid
yes she is really a russian party
plays out look at but overall
of course you can try to strain the Russian
Russian is not yet clear to Brigov
this is not a sentence this is not a horse c3
yes, but here again it's interesting what's what
sagrada fabio of course there were hundreds
Let's remember what it would have been like for him
this version of the Russian party was in one
from parties one can 11 party match on
the world championship was held in
it discussed the variant of the center and
and what will lead the knight to f6 again
curious love very curious
moment because there is white if they want
can play not so toothless
how did the world champion do it in this game
there finger extremely sharp and anish giri in the
on the air told a lot of interesting things about
I unfortunately watched this position
but that's just me that I that you still
remember the main option itself and won before
in early November and, accordingly, something
looked at something about it
really very wide perimeter where
blacks must reckon with some
just victims, let's say, well, if
will come to this the victims of [ __ ] and if
black people remember everything and it's a draw
like he's here let's say it's clear
that fabi did not go well in the decisive
match party wouldn't go for option
which he considers not not holding in
camtasia between played and
yes, horse f6 is such a fashionable fashionable
idea in this fighters but far from
the only thing you can achieve is 6 in both yourself
sat down 6 this toes old mod
vtb hunter what to her for some reason
got much less popular in
lately, well, the knight f6 is that
what we expect and again here you can
remember neither from saturates 76 until decided
not not to check decided not to check
training hikaru in complications after
knight f6
fabian given hikaru and here is the difficulty
software more or less yes not shocked
let's just say 6 yes here you are
finally got the view with the board
yes indeed Hikaru's last move
made h2h 4 very standard yes that is
put something knives 5 even on breaking
on the same 5 elephant on the same 5 and most often
the idea is exactly what to put conditionally
gres londa leotard g5 and out of it go yeah
and not a horse remains our 5 cm on it
attack pawn as much as white extremely
calmly leave him there
since the autopsy is not already in
in most cases will lead
matt still up to 6 to 5 played yes I'm here
I think if the party is still being repeated
robson robson caruana i'm sorry
haven't been back for a long time
analysis of the Russian party, therefore, that
party in which fabi before
walked-walked 6
I think there was something like
for some reason it seems to me 4k 6cd combi before
Friday the 4th went around here somewhere
version 85 is so strange but maybe
I might be hallucinating
one plays hikaru
corr does not yet determine the king in one
move is good, yes it is like this
how to say victor on and movement which
white players that all targets on sky to
your rita and citylink that's when not
know exactly what to do until I don't know what
here and there he obviously knows but there is
mind when whites don’t understand no
direct no game move king would be 100
there is no military well, such neatness
plus never have to think about how
react to the queen e5 because the queen
e5 days do not pose any threat and
care income can't be bad other
the point is that it may not always be
absolutely obligatory but harmful strongly
it can't be and the second party let's go on
take a second look at the second batch
because they already tell me there under
suggests that a very acute development
events I experience about the second
parties
a lot of mixed emotions because I
probably the main inspectors are your maxims
played this variant for last there
two years and a half do not know white pieces
with white pieces and with extremely bad
I got results several times.
close to the positions won with him in this
lines can be several it's bust one
time i got very very good
position in tbilisi in classic with him in
this line and couldn't party you game
then in rapida I lost the game to him again
lost in this line a game in beat where
I found it boring to play
absolutely correct I went to
exacerbation that did not develop in my
favor but I never went before 4
let's show how it turns out the knight f3
for 54 knight f6 knight 100 such an attempt is not
give them well our beloved greenfeld and he
stable here plays exactly like this
antigone filter up to 5 aka 6cd combi up to
5 4 knight to 4 bishop c4 now absolutely
central line
when you check the king is barely a knight in 4 checks
queens one here has a grip not d3
so transparent relatively fresh
never used to go like this before
automatically moved knight e6 what
own white made eat crust
endocrine white does not always make him
knight plays e6 i in response to this with him
varied the move up to 3 4 you could start
up to 3 you can start with 4 there are differences
wait b4 here too and of course yes
there is an old theory of beginners coming off by 4
in response to what kind of like in the current
state of affairs says in black must
sacrifice this pawn bc bishop same 7 to 4
here let's say cavalry 603 you are reading this
labor and yes yes monstrously wound up
position that I once tried
how about
relatively high quality
analyze not sure what I have
turned out as it should, but at least
Least I tried well, here's a lemon today
made a move that
I definitely didn't watch them ordered honestly
speaking also does not look like a man
who knows exactly what's going on
doesn't look happy
yes, it tells me that there are only six
once there was a move up to 24, that is, here
such a completely fresh position
offhand for a discount is not very clear
why not capture for this pawn and what
it is white in response to this they mean
how many to 4 looks a little over
scary potash immediately begin to appear
some horrors are connected with the course of words
ready 7 there as it seems what can
wrap and lose plus maybe
there is some knight move b5 here again
such a trap if Kolka 5 caused mbi
25 naturally
the basics of traceology, then everything is my first up to 8 and
black suddenly find themselves without
queen before behind yes and if we say knight 86
the most natural move we can serve
island 4-5 so black can walk
because we defended Ferdinand 8 and
more weakly it doesn't win by everyone anymore
so I can't say right now
why can't you capture this pawn maybe
elephant and at four immediately again creating
strongest load knight bo5 she knight c6 y
we have another field that we can
use dp to use with that
for now, give the e-75 as a goal, it seems not
very important because yes, that is, we
broke through and of course you can go and
prices, too, which is probably a little more
conservatively does not release well then
I’ll probably put the horse up to 5 in this meta
most likely because we are difficult
believe that we must be strong
scared of blacks, that's absolutely the same as
wouldn't it be quite senseless they
hear I forgot to say goodbye before therefore
most likely or horse fight on TV md5
I don't know which one is stronger
yes tip b5 marten 6 i'm not through
understand how to take it they manage
you will attack families, yes, probably horses, well
let's say the cavalry herself went 6 and now
some extremely strange finger
appears on the board in which it is, well, bye
the horse is standing on d5, yes, and I can imagine
imagine even knew won gh4 exactly
this is exactly what i wanted to suggest
because black want absolutely
definitely black want the same 6 by 7
castle short so we play h4
get ready to meet our 6
black move h5 to bishop 7 for example
there is photo 6 although I think there is
some more ambitious lines
for example, something that I did not find by samvel
there is a very interesting idea here
move queen d2 creating maybe
just a threat but there in response to some
senseless pass expect yazh 808 and first
queen on usa often making effect
enters the game through the field from 6 to
I'll take the black don't have to [ __ ] pass
up to 2 here, for example, the figures stand like this
maybe even shock
fire under enemy fire and since
version as if the [ __ ] could
packs 4 black [ __ ] stage
4 couple do not reach offhand do not reach
right away at least that's why
scary black but so I don't see and not
lose and in general of course
very interesting idea again remains
obscure
does it roughly disprove
black formation or this idea on one
party, such ideas usually end up on
one but judging because the answer is black yet
no no no demonstrated light
surprise yes and this is important this very
one batch of levon you chose pretty
well cuz im we'll take over
Feels unprepared for this move
at least to the teeth given very much
interesting and then it is of course combi up to 4
planned that well i i enters 04 i almost
sure that he is on the green wall is logical
this is so I don’t understand how I sold more expensive
eight to the right of the first there is only g8 but
even king e-8 queen h5 same 6 considering
how much we ate black this is unlikely
you want to take this three figures
ran a full floodplain 8c vital
whether the elephant is cheaper 16 4-ku not dealt all
active non cities per word 4 maybe
you might want to think about going
although no, I wanted to say what 6 are
some move on such up to 45 in fact
actually looks really creepy
threats actually in whites
four orders, we again recall that
almost never until
look at f3 yes until he went to the knight
reset coins to 4 can only leave
on record can be and how many not 6
let's say but then it is possible in some
compensation simply after the exchange of queens
believe honestly, moreover, I'm thinking
services b8 seemed to win on the spot
because if dad me and queens then
chance b5 then chance b5 is not a check
in a good way the end of the party so black
forced to kill on 8 immediately and up to
so that I can go firsa 4 elephant to 7
beta 7 let's say because row 1 is like
minimum
maybe there is something more
aggressive here then well here now
here really looks to be over
how dangerous 407 can be bishop b5 though
split photo 6 what i'm shaking let's say if
word 5 so die see it just
end because
offer family brace no 5 protect against
rather dangerous photo ch 7 double checkmate
will difficulty menacing up neighbor 3
step to the gun alone does not improve much
the position of the black block 70 is equal to
terrible threats and we are ready to like
love you risk hunting with them 6 but
Again, let's not get carried away because
enough I think to say about this
position that she's insanely scared and for
blacks and
you need good nerves to go for it
without preparation
Yes, I think that in this party we are very
we won’t wait for a reaction from maxim for a long time
he needs kilograms of course here
it's good to assess what's going on
the second batch as a whole we observe that
it feels like they're both pretty
well prepared for what's going on
first and second
Hikaru really has it for sure
nicer here let's say this move
events pro and so fast according to king
bo1 as if at 6 no he owns 80 fabian
elephant to 3 slate 5 also, as it were, the move is not not
quite very not the most suggestive
I was scared I would like a trailer
tesla has already made 5 or 4 elephants Nafikov has made
much more discreet services 3d 4
black times two or white horse structure
f6
yes knight f6 water yes and one knight 4 firs
4 and fabiana already gone Feb 6
they say it's just an exact repetition
party karl she white vs kettlebell here
food ferrari ocean weights sorry yes i
I commit not at six already with reagents
well, nevertheless, but again in these
white structures are undoubtedly better
elephant I came up substantially better elephant before
3 than bishop c8
but absolutely symmetrical and harmonious
as much as I don't, I don't mean by party
the position is a draw, and even then it is not clear that
the party is not over but I suspect that
very, very difficult is something
won against against qualified
mother with what Fabian and no doubt
is to prove something
thoroughly and White's advantage is such
fingers would be extremely hard though of course
you can try if the whites are there if you give
white a certain number of mods in a row
three in three same 4 there something
position can become quite for what
reaction on a horse 5 the same 4 I thought that u
they will buy you 6 as if just not to yawn
he is a little embarrassed by the prospect today
no regrets or or
whether not to the end yet it's hard to say yes
then some kind of servant 6 initially or
immediately discuss on i-16 because
on the apple, too, do sin cara immediately more
it may be possible and not to rush with
this while he will play 3 attack can
be some move still and took off from her
four
I'm scared for some reason, I'm not sure
about this change in structure, what do I think
I'll say this is the same fabric at e3 for lunch I
4 is clearly impossible and all f6
we'll show the darkening before we'll show why but
here's some sort of rearrangement to
im moving to e3 then white is there
start 4-2 shorter not a good bow
I have arrows, let's assume
servants 6 to her 3.6 fix i dont know
how much is
to the pool yes you will and therefore it is necessary
more carefully what you need to say and everyone
at 5 to and we in response to this go say
Well you are putting up a breakwater flags 6
horses 3 well, let's say if you imagine
what black here gave white 2 tempi
so big and maybe believed
so that white can play to win that
hearts 3
these two pace they'll give up the king
comes to the flowers and then we start
try to hold up 4 to 5 lucky
reactions but instead go to black
rook up 8 then water up 1st gay 8
will be held at 5 to 4 if possible
only to dream about
everything was so cloudless not that
so that Bella is worse, but I am superior
I think that there is no question
therefore, on the knight 5ml, the set of moves is 0 plus
of course you can and fasting can be conditional
telling me 66 f3 knight to 7 rendered yes
to change horses
and not even beat on not 5ive but even
he is 4 in the 6th grade of his foundation si
yes, that's exactly what it says in
such service collected Gelfand a lot I'm in
I will not pass this position and I remember somehow
turned out not some nicer in
the Russians drew naturally went
after the party analyze it was still
in those years when he almost went after
analyze it unfortunately culture in
Kindergarten is to blame the world is dying yes I am and on
actually unfortunately because a lot
interesting me as a young man
learned by analyzing with elders
comrades, we somehow sat down, I'll look here
I have nicer elephants, I have some
were against the glory of the horses without going there
of course nicer well, and a little I don't
I will understand the new here I will not lose said and
it was so well let's go back to the current
positions there in fabia because in this
games we will show you once again the current
finger and switch all the same to to
ipad thinks that means hikaru
hikaru king c1 koru would go shorter than 11
well, as if one c1 is quite some
if part of the tooth before that is allowing
tempo valley that she behold king and fassino
winking one fruit is actually up
the fact that money one camp one serves
4k no 5 camp 8 then paddle on
reverse use this actually
such as cynicism which can be
gives white some hope king two
sun 83 show off so we don't need but we can
and so the sky can parade
I don't think white people are serious about much
here
well, there is indeed a possibility
what hikaru
this is the practical decision
try to play carry the weight
given but short control where undoubtedly
he will definitely be the favorite of the Romans for
but also
and once again we will repeat the game
over and if black well, completely
will play it with one of those fingers
which it is important not to include at all
autopilot than because its quite possible
lose if there is some and do
nonsense when if some time
hold in absolute conviction that
white want to offer a draw further
really wait for the offer to move
said until if if case gathering and waiting
until the enemy has yet to offer somehow
refuses to some extent
to detect a dick will no longer offer yes and
and then there will be problems, but then again
Fabian all these things we do not explain
he should be aware and we do not expect from him
such a naive attitude towards this
party in regard
[music]
hikaru there hikaru obviously appreciated
appreciated his
expectation and attempts to win one
a game of classics or an attempt to win
match within a match 6 pairs of rapid type and
blitz and came to the conclusion that expectation
tomorrow is higher than this expectation
today I think it is
describes this approach and
yes we all see more and more
Actually this is the attitude of the world champion
are, it seems to me, the flagship of this
the relationship given here is interesting you know
the one we are talking about as a kind of knockout
which could end now yes
if you win hikaru and actually
in fact, the game about the match continued
equals well yes of us dough mutu
firstly, this is a plus for you
no less can be undoubtedly the Russian party
contains more ambitious attempts
the pastor put them on even the country is white in
which are there by the 18th move on the board
more figure somewhat less
symmetrical structures
we don't judge we don't judge hikaru
cult, for example, offhand I won’t say
how to go to get more
us to win the russian party this question
which is of interest to many
the answer to it seems official to me
not now, but still sure
how is the urinary situation
Hikaru suits them so chose
a finger in which there is absolutely no risk
so beat on 1a taken on and 10 killed
one respectively elephant will go somewhere
you can on the same 4 you can immediately over all
by the way, because she was returning
then you can go there korolev 8
also go while also not identifying the elephant
there wouldn't even be 5 options actually
here we can consider eight queens
5 horses and now I wanted to finish
our white members there will all be as soon as possible
everything you can give by giving them yes you
budget to robert james wich fisher
same 4 then try as same 4
took not immediately but immediately you want without
died immediately on f2 but still long
one will be active yes it's sorry no 6
and you can immediately six on you need to check
same 6 well let's go let's say here h4 and h5
the king of all yes oh in short 7 you can
take even 6 took our 6 in the same we have it here
it is necessary to study such positions f3
v-track unexpectedly inflames the elephant
big right is she problems with margins
taking into account our ego, we drive it with a task
which he uses 8 then, as it were
verbatim with him looks silly on pick up
its in general the same barrier 8 is already possible but
until i brought dalmat to rhino 4
like more king e30 kings and
queens 4 or 5 and then I'll go elephant
8 and hope again we wouldn't
get involved is absolutely not
forced metal king 8 does not look
super quran i think there is a move
more successful again 17 does not threaten quieter
I will say after 978 you need to go back because
that Oleg and 88 before the rook is simply caught
leads to her
to the unfortunate consequence I think
let's not dig into this
spy, he will either become sharper or not
won't yes it's absolutely fair y
we have a second party in which by the way
move made move not made here not made
given move
as said move
for a long time apparently will not be done come on here
by speculating yes here interesting
the pawn must be captured because if
allow until field d5 appear black
will become close hopeless therefore choice
black is strictly between cd and combine
four other moves I will boldly lie
fingers does not contain other moves because
that it's not just not just pace it's still
and completely overwhelming positional
advantage there even if not but it is not
I really want to look for some headlights
seriously he then how would well so not
I don't want to take it seriously
it is clear what needs to be beaten than let's do it
just look at first it's finger to whom
to be more specific and start with the move
elephants 4 I'm not absolutely sure what he is
forced to remind us again
finally a6 what move to rings 6th
layout no again like her 6 here
it's important, I'm not saying that it's true
she actually seems to be
roll call i.e. Black can go to
some such positions yes it looks like
what can happen after cd by
picture black has an extra pawn for white
very nice knee until 5 pm somehow
develop figures so to speak already 6 cereals and
it is not clear how it is still developing, and now
here it is necessary to calculate the option as it should
to understand whether whites have
it's enough initiative 4 let's say there is
move h4 there is a cat version 4 may not be
meaningless or first b3 with some
similar ideas so that later la grandfathers one
out to pass like we're going at all
by the way, queen b3 what kind of game will we finish
check arrows let me down, but somehow
he promoted jesse
we listen less yes but specifically
often for some kind of move I don’t know
the impossibility of spreading that is such yes
those things when you threaten but
any reasonable percussion I don't defend
wanted to enroll geometry show on
Indeed, any move protects from it
in 1 the same number of seeds and men it has
unclear was watering 8 when
using 8 is probably not enough and in
case lodent d1 perhaps black can
castle and finally completely
calmly they will beat the elephant take
water up to 88 and here it is like above
it would not be clear even if it were
lockdown done covertly room 11
already horses again starts asian extremely not
extreme obscurity stasik. knight c6
how are we going then
refute for the whites and if we go
so what are they hitting?
here is also a question yes, because I take
a pawn on the board, it seems to me that a pawn
they hit what the fingers seem to me
hopeless and on a horse and 6 you have such
there are cavalry yes here I am again again
achieved the very same did not achieve
there is no desired result, yours is hidden
give the word rose in the sun 8 shah to the king
can't announce on f1 so here I am
just don't see the protection we need can
go and [ __ ] an elephant and 5 there is an elephant before the 6th
blanket white differently on stand
won we can eat all the pawns of the knight
f6
not but in niches also looks good on
I'm sorry I haven't woken up yet
end
so i think it might be a pawn
favorite yes and that's what I wanted to go
first blood
attack and everyone before to did not take dc difficult
but not worth an atom to 2 mod two moves
usually should not be allowed until if there is
There is a wide selection, but not very rich.
from the file, they withstood the ranks and 6.5 oh well
here it all depends on what they can and
black horses go again in this position
though really fierce that's a pawn
beat maxim yes well looks like them
once again they look crazy
scared me to them taking not quite not
liked it and can get away from it
finally because because it is not
liked it because it didn't work
we are good cd here we are
Yes, we proceed from the fact that when I have no one
not afraid
then 5 6 we consider huge
an outsider in this race, he is already a little
does not meet the spirit of the same strange it
weird habit to admit mine 4
just give black two bishops again
if
if you can think of some way in this
you can look at the same positions, but
seed 6 threatens and
how how to add up hits on a pawn up
what is not clear md5 except that 6 there I am not
to the end I see in general it looks like
artificially very probably again I still
maybe I can go alone here
elephant reached me the structure is incomprehensible
1 to 4 wanna pick up skillfully at 6
I was going to pick up I need 4 but that's me not
sure you lose your figure you want let me go
I do not see the skin only from the hunt and the neck
according to the plan it was further up to 4 step from the moons up to
7 there were grains well yes then there were spent
elephant up family
slambed will only kill us, and here we are not
right pecha full height sadness we are not
right full body so fierce wait
elephant bits 6 come on come back what
destroyed what's up to the opinion that we're not
see if he believes that u
he is still better than this position then
what threatens version 4 step but when you
extremely such people 4 well honestly i
not quite straight even if the elephant needs to be
leaves, I understand that I need to want to go
even we can u white better here it is
big at all but they or immediately
jump up or they don't have a better say
plans 4 and that is, you think you need
very aggressive no naturally because
what about elephants scientists from chernus japan
66 nothing to give by now
so good and if i went marten 6 and how
we're going to the street again we'll be
call
dress up 85 or we'll go straight ahead
let's say immediately e5 then it's still white
can if at least we have to walk we can this
get a position if we want white and
well done 8 that again we will show that so
don't exchange no flag tan 7 up
hope 8
So
some reason not to walk the horse until 5
is in the course of the same elephant 5 here but
again, I'm not sure what happens if
Black, as it were, will open our bluff and go
let's say this position I don't know what
to the benefit because the knight is quite 8
understood stronger the Jew to be caught, yes, but
other than that, again, I don't know how
this is all myth 6 is refuted here I have a
he died and didn't rebut a lot of problems
gt6 muscle schedule [ __ ] even for my
position probably like this he and ballet or
or maybe this way
think again on a note by providing 6 here
when mentioned by evgeny it is very
nice, yours apparently needs to be beaten with a queen
tushino alive should queen h5 ha ha hah well
here that I believe that white is not here
succeed me extremely
let's roll back to the position that is on
board then tells me that the position
played three times
chess player by last name you know Arkady
Russians are such a ghoul and he is like that to me
seems not a very strong grandmaster
practical game but he rewrite these
you need people like this and like this when a person
some position is played by correspondence
and even then in the modern world, so to speak
this means that a position that is difficult
analyze even with computers because
what's in the rewrite on the game well doesn't have
it makes sense to play some direct
computer options are clear that everyone has
everyone uses a computer everyone
use the base you can have time to see
analyze norway before i.e.
people in the game of correspondence looking for some
position where even a computer can
somehow here to be mistaken to stray to give
some misjudgments anyway
the central line seems to me then of course
we defended ourselves against version 4 step
question I understand that you do not scare
graduation starts 6 well, and suddenly not and
this is first of all, yes, and it is necessary
is to study i think yes one bc remotes
how absurd I am for a second of you at
us how many absurd tina I'm like sorry
I can't dislike the locals, but I want to
there from the point of view of this
endgame which we discuss after
rings 66 let's say the top of the building on wanted
of course the king yes and translate it
there are two and then servants 3 rooks hd1
this is your king on the battle reached not
such positions are white
but they're not that every one of them look out
you can soak there completely
how absurd in terms of
king development here after f3 lion king
2 since he goes out the same whims one
there they need it could be such
on fingers think about 4 rooks h3 like
always often there always often
I don't speak Russian so well come on
somehow then black a little more to the queen
4 threatens still course on 4
still threaten well, maybe some
sluggish move here bishop a6 is there knight d7
why white is about 6 when you can have a knight
d7 covered for a frame from the first threats yes
probably 4 we will go, I think you can
as if the 6th can be impudent on occasion
while patil get dressed 8 aspirations with ears
pawn 7 pawn should be of great concern
semkina heaven turns out 5 will go label
everything will fall apart it starts to bother
so friends, is it not, yes, if you need words
e3 years
even 5 thought well, there are already 6 after all
leaving him under attack is overkill
after 5 to keep the e6 pawn off for now yes
well, let's say even while our 4 left, that is
drive me further if you want
elephant same 3
obviously not me in debt vsu elephant same sim card
not at 5 to 6 although he lives by the number of grandfathers
one wanted to check how I lose
after an accident 2, I finally attacked
3 with a check so well, here is some kind of checkmate
beautiful demonstrate until I see k
unfortunately demonstrate
how do you protect a servant like this up to 7 with a move 6
probably they di2 that lyuda cynicism both sat down
5 still have at least some yes probably
north but after this one can jump and
the same remember that the king can not
react to fasten some
moment here would be so serious
the addition of yes strength to the attack on the ladies is short
castling but when is not Ivan himself so
how much so that he does not have contours
king safe 2 hydrogen olla des h1
something is about to leave
played too much was not up to say there went
so so at the end of 5 well what is needed here
do nothing more condition 5
probably attack there, that is, even if
if up to black adze same 7 then i will
consider that I have won than
listen, there was not one cat left to do
short castling
and then agree something white that
slope e5 i probably actually sofa
and I think that and when you are already a check
on the sixth floor 8 I will find a mat on this
side of the board
some kind of breakage he beat the food
flesh income killed two houses in total it
that 7 tense addicted we clothed
obviously something is not there, but here is the maxim
is thinking seriously here because
once again returning to the fact that he is on the board
now he has x slando sun family
4 check, moreover, I will say that yes you at least
a little absurd, but in principle there is
grip and essence
take and most 6 virus to 1 combi d1s
then black comes out to her 6 aka 7
porridge peppers look unsympathetic but
as if the problem is that if white
somehow manage to lock up this elephant
conditionally like this and he does not go out
guessed white won
but most likely white lock him up here
do not have time put out at 4 we'll go e 5
on 5 5 after 6 and 5 immediately always
the same five appear here I am
I wouldn't be sure because f is the same and here
this network structure is white I'm not much
figures so that someone is seriously probably playing
though
castling 2 to 8 comes out it's not wrong
clear i'm on her three king barely that's what
such but on that there is such a position I like
since they are often encountered and of those
the options that i have there others wella
checked there let's say in the line that I'm with
im played which looks about
let's say up to 3-6 h4 let's say 6.5 black
can for example not a second h4 is
it turns out
h5 knight g5 same 6 pile in these lines
doesn't react, but only strikes on e6
blacks hit and hit and these fingers are really
actually much more obscure than even
here early really wanted so three in a row
go from these 4 and 5 here she will not give no
they will not give yes that's why in principle
vaet maxim entered logr literal
sense, I understand it would seem to him
no 8 am let me sent here
the young man's conscience is supposed to be here
so well let's get back to because
going on that check again and yet
king i'm the one looks we sing callin
looks like but you have to choose and again
we need to choose by weight because
we deeply analyze this fingers
live can't oregon obviously
knows where the edge we are like is this for what
still here i wonder 24 king
let's say one then yes knight c6
but if I play yes, let me do it too
would like to return if i play with it important
moment because it feels like I
I have the right not to hurry with the capture on c6
it is not clear how black continues
Well, again, a lot of things rests on
what we think for some here
such a pose before defended against version 4 check
and want water up to 8 in some she doesn't
now I also blunder a pawn on 7 immediately if
stretched white there doing some
useful move our 244 looks not on
silly yes and than somehow certain
problems with the development of the king elephant
rejoiced as if 8 of course not not
decoration positions here on the other side
so far nothing is black threat page 4
of 5 rooks h3 rook 6 approximately approximately
All in all, this is a very cool game.
obtained despite the symmetry
was an example wanted to go to the 6th to go
e50 if you took it and they won’t let you go
that's why
well, besides this, there is our lonely tree
of course, and some other moves, probably
suspected, well, it just seems to me that
now I want to beat on c6 understand
provided that you attack with a pawn, say yes to
e5 here I will become happy
iron is of course an improved version
I won't say that it's some kind of
luxury uh uh try to 3 3 batteries in
three stones four kings in the eye
Surely it could be even nicer
essentially depends on how
a lot of white scientists will succeed in such
fingers it is very important to try
organize the contours of the pear 54 which
will be very well controlled
move him with this knight for 4k
it will be extremely difficult for whites to want to go to
roles in 2
then sooner or later go sun 5
fix 25 one of the lungs and lips
not fountain fingers can and keeps but
no great joy
don't call u than so again
we return to the beginning, that is, from the point
vision
oddly enough from what we saw
queen of perfection archers i'm good at that
I will mention that this move exists
insofar as
another question what if i want to play you
your move bishop e3
then i can ignore it
true but we are on the other side we are
we won in terms of flexibility
we may again may not give this step
may not give four times after
which constantly hangs an elephant that is
each and maybe much more
satisfied with this position and the step is real
no need here m with polyarthritis the same
under attack, that is, after h4 you are not a count
wiry nothing apparently must that I
I have to do I don't know what to do
do scientists here actually
little by little they want to go out through
corner there somehow h5 then maybe on
in fact, at 6 the king at 7 is 6 like this
in general, the practical decision is made
introduced because I suspect that from the point
vision as if hard
hard exit to the equation probably
Slonovski 6 would be better taken away, but here
he thought he was playing obviously
against a well-prepared opponent
who surprised him in the opening gave him
already half an hour on the clock and therefore
a move is chosen after which they beat Lebanon and 6
meanwhile, he was not particularly surprised
takes the elephant and then what about us
shows nakamura there still apparently
something happened there
continue to continue the figures leave with
avast boards somewhere, he is a partisan
went just korolev 8 king to 2 come on
I take out his indicator on king 8 not
followed by horses 5 on led to us
about the same, the only thing is
if he starts scania 5 tons of water in
the answer to the move as many as 7 and 6 which won in
parties can go to 3 and prevent
conchita in the end him about nikon d700
blacks can pull
here I am this exchange this will take place before
so hikaru went to king 2 and black
just go a6 college 4 but maybe
here to go to 3 you can go to 4 but even
Let's say if you imagine something like this
although such a back structure may be i
I believe that whites are much more pleasant
hard no well who happy i found out about
I can easily see nothing
here and don't try and don't try anything
it's easy to say here, but maybe
some kind of all the same there is a clue because
what again if you make parquet
naive moves in 5 king e3 and
king f4 actually counts
dangerous why there on traffic but on 4
for example, one might consider
their move is 2
although I'm not sure what we want to leave
a light-squared bishop against this
knight d5 hole then even serve 4 yes you
serve 4 me move interested extinguished
at 5 we managed to look through and 8 I didn't
I have time not to cross yes yes the field at 4
for this I would probably have some idea
there is an active change in the structure of the course and
in 666 undermine on occasion then maybe
not immediately, but if necessary, you can immediately
maybe there you can from our without
haste to stay white minute which she
only harm falls on a white field
Description 2 I'll put the geese step no we
we argue, we call manners here
line6 bass models at this moment black
no one rushes they could start with h5
let's suppose the date is 6 rook rook
of course that's the position whether my darlings should
apparently play h 5d went h5 hikaru beats
for the same 4 days before the fig in general loves
rapid chess and
in general, you can turn everything
discussions whether she analyzes here is similar
that now Fabian will go rook 88 and
well, yes, as if the optical belov is better
words but still not in position 7 by 7
symmetrical structure
demonstrate that we have better words
Black sets up 5 6 on the King's
flank, and your words should be 7 and, as it were, with
look the enemy in the eye with interest
so fabia
he still looks perfect
right does not make a move for one
checks for a second if there are any
pitfalls
but water and 8 plays yes and apparently you
ask contributed if yes if so be
quite honest and see remains with us
one batch for today after that before
took took but yesterday the guys played
a very interesting match among themselves
it can be seen that the facts are just the opposite
really wanted White to have maximum problems
put in front of the hikaru some and
really put serious
problems but just raw on the truth but
couldn't win and hikaru in general
carries bears bears in general takes to itself
such a day off today and endures
all the weight on borrow tomorrow anyway
winner will be determined tomorrow
one for need shortened well again
we repeat that this is an approach that
her chance here is like a revolutionary
this approach, but it is the main
popularizer of this mathematical
roughly speaking approach to the odds
finished playing by chance this is it
definitely let's clean up sure already with
screen this position until the opposition is not sonar
so inspiring but also lego does
fund move two again which
shows that this spy also looked
and the tank itself, because we have here too
ending but much more started but the idea
to try not to let go
at least comfortable words in big
diagonal
here black will need a little some
antics and jumps it won't play they
like two worth showing to the soul 7
same 6 then really on shook on
basis
but again black in terms of
where they keep pawns and it seems to me that in
ideally maxim would like to keep them on
fields and family 6 you can of course go and 5
sun 36 to her three but we ran out of her
and 605 where she potentially becomes
object of attack
here we will also say specifically this position
looks absolutely fine for what
maybe it’s white deeds for someone
it may not be necessary to demonstrate on e5
hurry up with the sun 3 just move
need to try can control
there is only one way out
our very words to ourselves jump nd4 us
it’s not enough, but we just need names nicely
do not let it go 4 let the horse walk on
up to 4 by that pawns 5 will hang
ta well, that means they are a little
reminiscent of some variants from Philidor
here is an exchange if the bishop plays black up to 6
say cavalry 4 king king have m
sales step chain well yes in general here
no structure here is the sun semashko
doing it already is an unpleasant position
in the corridor they are considered rather vile
as far as I know in particular if
white manages to break up, I think he
all three horses often they try
translate specifically for david extinguished d3
black defense initial may try
comment attack him with bo 75 and on
box up to 3 he's having the hardest
the pressure on the e5-pawn is absolutely
unattainable for him, let's say with
knight up to 3 may still be worth mentioning here
structure some elephant c3 suppose we
play it again it's sketchy it
not move knight d4 took may
the heaviest let's say further hitting even
whether the king on d3 or the knight is real
hell really bad finish housing real
position and black passed pawn
lose not every time but in general
they understand that the situation in them is quite
critical here because the elephant
remains bad and the horse again either or
in the area enjoys or you where better
probably move the horse inside later
try where 454 use price line
that is while being an ordinary heavy stance
most on the kingside
starts to affect therefore and 5 in general
responsible decision is here for im business
which I think that if he accepts then
will take after pretty seriously well
let's say 6 is really ours
sun 3 and go with mountain water below 8 then
there is not the most pleasant, well, here
after exchanging bishops and Azuna with a large
comfort yes 6 no I definitely yes
because
conditionally for three is objectively better
passive gloriously black let's say so
that is, here in these fingers again
repeat if we imagine black
brought the words satisfied to 4k, not a single one
no problem but it might not be the case
easy here to the field to 4 to bring therefore
idea in principle x not from the board
changing through what is with the arrows
everyone look, I'm already 4 probably white again
maybe yes yes maybe I should go
h5 because that's allowed
we will also beat or immediately I thought at all
rooks h3 frankly while can h5
don't even go so that the bull eats the rook
need flexibly which side is enough
let's say beat yes it's all on thin
then you went around and grandfather 8 second on f8
it won't be very bad but from another country
of course it is clear that he skillfully killed and ate her
try such e3 let's say somehow f3 1
put on the water before 2 of the poppy end of 4
we drive her back, it’s obvious what was beating
it will be nicer but again black
maybe
suggest that they do not have this fingers
must lose dollars neat
to be honest, it will be small
disappointment for me when there's no one
fails to take 6 points in one set of three
it’s clear whose draw is yes, here are the [ __ ] in one
parties 6 . yes it is so far with us
the main success of Aronian, but in this opening
then probably still bent for an hour 40
minutes difficult hours
serious enough even in such a
would be a simplified position not harmful not
harmful not harmful transferred here
what other possibilities are we not here
mentioned
the bishop on f8 and how should you develop
so it really seems to me that
Here the choice is between
trying to go the same 6 then change it
on a large diagonal or maybe everything
still try as much as possible with a bayonet
because the game ski 5 6 sun 5 she
aimed at some complete total
level if it turns out of course if
if it works out which is far from up to
they didn’t tell us there some
the moment that exactly the course of the flask 86 immediately I
fought a novelty in this guy before that here
this is all
as already mentioned met where yes well
and we will show again here Hikaru is not very
lucky in the game against Fabian because
that elephants inside cannot be changed
otherwise he would have been great and
checkerboard construction he's on half mind all
it's time to put everything on
well, yes he is, but they already had that now to me
I think I'll shake new breasts and because
already clearly looking around in search of
referee yes this is bloggers patrol hug
what a wonderful yes so but somewhere
walks yes today just technique technique
this particular how to say triple
sheepskin coats are showing good
participants
coped thirty-second care here
welcome anastasia sorokina to
screen you don't know if she's the main orbiter
or that you only need to name an organ
the chief arbiter there is always Laurent Freud
Anastasia is probably the first first assistant
captain
mbl went and 6 and 5 6 5 went for a walk and
finally went before he was let go
finally what do we have in this suit
after six
how we planned the sun 3 before but after
meaning no sun 3 we take control
over the lake here finally confirmed before
the guys were confirmed that all 6 points
scored for
until the day well done whisk but there are two very
different of course ours and
maybe yes maybe hikaru a little bit
scold for refusing to fight but then
what happened yesterday in some
degree explains what happened today
inscription he escaped defeat by a miracle not
miraculously the nose was clearly doubtful
hikaru's position yesterday
defended well and today is like this
a tactical move or something in order to
ask fabian rapid chess again
in general, as if taking the general form
enter the competition in these formats and
the difference in the rankings is even so pure
it is formally clear that hikaru starts
pretty serious favorite in this 2f
comes to the left, which just pleases me
me because we have a horse on d3
they talked about what exactly up to 3
they c4 is the maximum maximum
correct position for this figure
generally say on the water up to 8 in it
planned for this arrangement is aslan
e36
let's say so far even getting along 1 and then konev
2 king barely
and we are always ready just not up to 400 not
depends on what black will beat
you need 4 yes, really, here's some
this arrangement is not planned
the beauty of something to start so and again
if you want to get along right away
one play don't give sun 5 up or
Bishop e3 play well one of these two
moves to I don't know which one is more accurate
me by the year to determine actually
maybe we don't spend the growth rate on
in this fingers say immediately leave at 22
up on any move 11 1 anyway
will go to the fact that our canada 3 actually
for you for spending on than this on d1
and anoint
so let's do a few moves
just show when that's knocked out and
plans to give cheese to think that the elephant before
2 and 3 is coming
a lemon walks in response, although again it’s up to you
he is cunning
culture to the masses
this is the final stop at 3 and 4 and
and under this shield, as it were, an elephant is an elephant on
e3 it's very so everything is so according to the laws of the genre
connection with which I have a question like this
try now some jumps
organize some 4 the truth i don't
I fully understand that she is so yes, well, so
debt very long very long but well
or what, again, you can do something
similar after up to 8 years the same
transition to the question on the distance is shorter and
in short, yes, under the distance but not over
quantity mono not quantity come on
let's try nevertheless delivery 4 horse in
20 you wanted a horse almost a thread on 4 care
really stupid because
up to what I can
ignore it catch up even in you wanna
paratus took took yes you want please
scatter all the pieces on the correct squares and
and now in general something with blacks is not
lose immediately can endure there an elephant
up to 64 king e7
barely there like the sun is seven baby
news in general yes it is possible and even a draw
black she here to do and here
fun to get in this party
difficult, and besides that, there is
of course, others of them 1 4 thousand can
buy it get away one tushino hardly
we want a stone for 27, that is, get along 7
looks pretty creepy
again, and you can lose on it
but it looks scary then so they have two
horse at 4 end 4 which means well then
yes, it is clear that white with such an active
I own on the seventh row does not risk
no risk at all and black here
yet
Absolutely nothing here yet clear answer yes
let's look then at mine here these
bombs 4 we assume we play right away
knight in dvaraka him two bishops 5 to 3
say over 100
but after being so messed up
structure, I think even this is the same
position it is not exactly equal to a3 you
you want or or maybe a king and not
carly 20
not to fall under chance up to 4 at once
immediately let's say of course king e7
king e3 yes we end up i want
make up conditionally talking about keeps
one goes well 3 athrill aviation 1 and then
I will still have a debate and hint for a moment
to what
paddles of weakness now 2
initially if we were talking about the fact that in
black police have only one weakness
that's why and 5 yes that's why
maybe it's not that bad
then if you create another one on the field b6 then
already in general but on the other hand
the alternative is that's it
quite passive from the main
stop with bishop on d6
royal and the wall, well, conditionally you can
somehow, of course, just go to 6-ku not in
2 party I don't know and don't be afraid of what
king diapers want binary sem
put on the fifth step of the jeep, yes, I
thought 6 king and 7 for 6 months j
embeds the same there already 4 5 times fix
well, some conditionally speaking the picture will be
about the same content
to 3 get along 8 I'm waiting for the fall of the owner 1 and
here we go here and again everything is everything
we repeat the same match about the fact that
we do not claim that this is won for
white but of course only white
enjoy the process here.
there, and quite unpretentious apparently
just for double pozzi and then catered
h5 almost always mp1 even the ladies were moved
until you pull this, let's wait for the gaish from everyone
sides of him and trying to figure out where he is
maybe give some slack and here
the same wording again
your yesterdays what can you do here
draw but cannot be called in this position
conceived our actively discussing for some reason
points from the world in blitz and rapid
coming to ask who will be there
play but I think that's what I think
it seems that somewhere in the open spaces
Internet, you can already find some
preliminary compassionate list
people who have confirmed their participation
so as far as we know the mangles will be
play the magus will play exactly the question
how many super grands will i come
I know that viswanathan anand is coming
because we are making some plans with him
on
spending time together roshon in koi
forever times turns out to be my hometown
we have plans for it so you look here
the very same advantage of 40 minutes
which has become even more no no yes
and some other move may affect
20 moves already not done close not done
20 moves until 16 16 honda until 16 done
and the position is that May 6 to May 8 is
it was you who went yes yes yes no gypsy gypsy move
hold back 1 and 6 up in response to that white
rook on 8 should be and this is mine
the other is just different in face
daish and servants 3 think and think maxim
I feel like I've tried everything possible.
to stop in general salaries 4
rejected as described as it seems to me
more of the possible approaches because
in a good way, they probably need a lot of ideas
try all the same to change the black-field
elephants no problem what is needed for this
will apparently spoil the structure
because I would have dug 6 so offhand
can't offer
as realistic as possible than outdoor
elephants to change except through through would
6 or worse through same 5 iron 656
coordinated to make all these moves in
the answer to that is white on service 32 and
to the greeting and ask actually
why wipe im then aimed at
control we have no back I understand in
this position how would you play and 5 played
i 6 to develop the bishop this diagonal
and suddenly change your mind and start Shiite pawns
for centuries it's a liberty yes it is
looks very, very suspicious
honestly up accordingly here is there is
plan associated with through certain fields
translations she would have 6 attempts or change
them or translate it 4 soon
change or you can still borrow here
such a position on the part and madri king is not
moved the rook did not move make a long
castling dick king c7 sourly point
on b6
the plan is such a hodor what order are we
all
I don’t know, well, suppose scrapping would be 4 that’s how
we went out and in this percentage of guys in
this threatens for example to go 3 0 to the role
it's good and two conditionally saying yes
good king roommate tape what dc1
kings c7 will securely hold
not easy yes really only already
problems started and quite
fundamentally it's shorter than the start menu is simple
very bad brain harold 7 idea
bad jandro
I'm looking at box 8, I'm already
I would seriously start studying the attempt with White
transform positional
advantage actual although it may be
after getting along 8 i don't have any
a good fork jumped but well, also white
still good but no reason
give quality if you count only about
that what's just good we have for
him good compensation about what it is
it is quite possible to make a move
make on the kingside
again, I remind you that h4 and h5 are in
most cases
Strengthening White's position
Yes
will give already well, that is, convincing
some convincing arrangement for
repentance I cut coffins until I see it yet
I don't see it, and he himself, of course, doesn't either.
not super happy frankly because
that's outsmarted by a lemon donut way up
elephant before 2 elephants three such beautiful water
and in general an option even a few words
dream details how much yes here is 9 to 4 and here I am
well very much like a feel no pain what
called because maxim is one of
the greatest theorists of our time, but
at the same time he is very fundamental
do not like to defend their perimeter
jump
from options accident to option yes and
this is in general and I am for because I myself am so
I have been living for decades and this is with
one side is easier because
option the same danylyshyn you below
give people the opportunity to prepare
. yes yes and obviously that again lemon
was well aware of all those parties
who say I personally was going white to
this option and again i need them well
as served a disservice by losing to him
a couple of pieces 6 white
he calmed down because
I didn't give him a reason to change at all
a record, yes, and probably by the way
advice is so interesting
gaytsov that when preparing they are on not on
this highest level somewhere here is someone
of our listeners may be playing in
tournaments are prepared by someone
some parties that should be addressed
probably the first attention
preparation for a specific opponent on
portico throne wins because he
unlikely to be there further to dig until if
if you believe in a position that
which he say for the other side
wins then so look
divided opinion in the chat and decided
read what is written in the chat there is an opinion
that Levon will torment Maxim for 100 moves
and a second opinion is immediately following
line again quickly draw but this
rather, in some areas you can
about another couple, I even about another
Party here quickly won't be here yet
definitely because there is no
the occasion was the bill of the pelvis of the countries is not a miracle
cases this and and slow draw here is not
very happy goals thoroughly
nicer without any
there is no risk in this party
quickly nothing will happen and in sight of that
concerns nakamura who need it party
certainly
not a little 5 saddened us how
commentators because she herself was
let's say not super interesting plus in
tournament in which there are only 2 games per day
of course we play much easier
work when possible
switch up between between batches then
but here nevertheless it seems to me through
I don't know, literally in hours
start a crisis in time for something that
Levon again, the moves are simple and clear and
more or less
Well, yes, Maxim once began to think
continues and continues continues and how
we already said you can't see simple simple
solution mode is not visible even tell me
problem solving but but just like that
is put to ever be even
suppose your position is worse
anyway, you finally understand what to do
before a gift but still it is not clear what
make completely completely obscure
suggests no arrangement then
eat
you need something like this
is called a leap of faith or are you taking
passive position you say I don't
lose or create yourself let's say more
you tell me one weakness is more important to remove
than the floor boards on the wife, look
by the way leaps of faith and another weakness
If you don't create any weakness, I walk nothing
bishop e7 king and all of us two downs here
new new version tell me everyone
long time in 2 turned to he not much so
here he played even then did not interfere under
kicked let's say let's say the king
barely come on I went up to 88 to d3 and here I am
started two somehow planet 7
go say rook
then rook to 8 here first i can
think about the elephant yes you can take
on c6 I can think about the bishop especially
given that it is important to hang your
variant that is disgusting to that so it can
maybe we wouldn't win with white
such a position
and here it is very important that it is higher in the b8 way
that it is important even I was for a second
doesn't that make black a forced
nothing will be here it would be a draw
here it would be a draw on foot 6 is
move bishop b8 whose nothing is already black
probably won't do it in the first place
second, there is still an opportunity to just go
hope one yes and in this position can
be swap one by one by me here
thought about this meaning i can be
then I killed a million paces why am I like this
do ugly go to role dual clothes
8 and hit the clothes and change one later
samba 4 walks pieces played service 4 yes
here to end this discussion
because four rooks off don't want a
the door seems to me to have a horse
inside is never fun like this
position
great fun then she
delivers to the leader of the white pieces
because, well, again, yes, yes, and
let's move on like this
subtle process of looking for weaknesses
and aggregates and is given three b3 can be from
either 4 then a4 b5 try to hold in
ideal
tactics and black has to stand
next 30 moves and accurately reflect
all attacks of white but instead of this
Maxim makes a move that we are very
lamps 4 in 2 have already been actively discussed
body cost if he decided on here
these are changes in the structure by creating
more additional weaknesses yes here it is
decided that it is less and less
due to
yes and at some point you know me
even it seemed maybe white can
play knight c3 elephant b6 cavalry 5 well
probably not, and we have no plains and
right i don't think it's right
because
some kind of position and win
mountain will be harder than not yet required
instantly beat and here is an interesting moment
second they hallucinate me i'm outta
with respect to the pace and thought that we were but we
6 was especially the king barely come on a little
less than 3 no killed no double vision on foot
after all, the king hardly played mine yet
scrapped b6 and now white probably has
no choice yes of course
meet pick beat sometimes king
fail beat on you 6 up beat beat
and then finally cod is a nasty walker
do not poke a step, it is necessary to consider the stages
so you can start right away
getting along
in order to say to the king e7 to move
horse inside on the card step calm and
king e3 what we took selling fire
or called probably quite empty
now good news for black after
the exchange of elephants, which is finally possible somehow
crown all queens 6 become protect
must be accepted
well, plus I think that one of
potential sources for interviews for
blacks here it's say again note
as if inside you can probably try
move rook 4 then rook asha 8
force white and theater or rook again
citizens holding e5 pawn under control yes
according to the meaning before the movement of point b and try
then somehow pierce 4 to change everything
still buckle she would pawn but then again
given how not poorly controlled
white field by 4
it's still the same maybe yes not the crowd
so as not to beat on b6 but for you
please that is either claims that
this little one is enough for him
weakness on e5 is obvious for Denmark
me decision for goose on black or killed
a huge amount of pace to
translate words to b6 maybe
specifically here just was a good take
took the king there m as how white
create but somehow I also had some
dreams about what to be held 1
then I'll go alone myself then I'll go skin 4
and I'll just remove the pawn from the board, but rather
in just as many moves they could for years
asian 100 grams serves me do not
give somehow not toothless is it a little bit
a bit surprising that the other side
he still has 6 on the clock
so maybe he just knows that
slumber b6 leads to kingdom after
neat games because
but again, it is not at all considered how
knight c6 in the greenhouse would be strange pain ta
speed who was the deal sandu 2 she
so hinting at not everyone was there
studied to the end we know and considering
what was the first thing we started discussing in this
position is perego with a bishop and 6 hard
imagine that he and his
brigade not catching up lying team up
Lebanese, his team did not guess what it was
one of the most important plans that are black
try to pass here therefore again
let's not criticize the decision by phone
clothes one from the person who has on
hours often it 652
yes already in the 20s the ladies are approaching up
time is actually not the background is correct
walks wasted time in prague
Yes, and here is another surprise for Maxim
actually because maxim expected
expected
the perfect eraser wasted your time yeah
here you choose between plans just
wasted time trying to figure it out
how much these weaknesses along the line b basis
the clutch would not refine adequately
pawns but the Assad line is not opened
everywhere well black stars can go on
insist there you can sip and the king
e7 I will say, not paying attention, they covered themselves
maybe step g5 I'm not sure if that's the case
on it's not I can be here on
let's get along on d7 so the servants went
3 on the other three back
yes something is not clear how then why
why did we run into good we ran into
the garden can't
can't rule it all out
yes it looks like you still have to beat
well, it begs to be taken, but once again
let's repeat that and maybe over here
what could he be
and bishop d4 by the way, yes, they still talked about
that as if it didn’t get any more accurate
we are told these much we will say bye
passed the horse to 30 or beat the father alone
we couldn't play we can well that's how it is
I myself would have two boats, I would have one, I think we
arrange absolutely yes it’s not for him
king and there are seven and now and now what
now everything is not clear now I
taking need 4 doesn't look like that anymore
attractive must be considered
again, not even really
some kind of position you can’t say what
I need it I'm not even sure
absolutely equal but because yes if we
we have time to go the horse inside then tell
i five king in 3 crown 4 vs
elephant and november on winning anya will
profitable but in case sense .
black must somehow actively try
this can be prevented
be wider than g5 for example or even
some fingers often walk at all 5
to desire the same 8 then a6 a4 a6
try to somehow immediately create
control on the royal because if
if they don't create it, they'll eat it
gradually the nose of a monstrous inevitability
they will be eaten in such a situation, yes, that is
Bishop to 4 also we are not completely sure
that's good but you'll come back to
the very simplest option with
by exchanging for and 3 by moving king e7 like this
blacks admit that it is a little worse and
neat game will try admix
I guess we're getting along on one with that one
or another version for simple option 1
this is what we discussed
position us either the knight before 3 or the end of 4
up to 5 questions more than answers
I'm actually about biladi save in general
Yes, let's say we didn't want to change you
a couple here because we don't need to create
do not create a threat go well 5 potash
in principle, 2 to 6 is normal for her
date everything is all a bit empty ah
why exactly 4 they are for the 3rd floor from the inside
I don't understand what I want from life
we all want a what the same owners
5 stole in the 6 and surrounded the token back
over at 6 yes i had eaten no box at
6 at the king or even breathe like this
as if even this finger is not completely
we almost achieved the same
maximum scientists changed very bad
her words are very good but still u
me water outside boruto but here it is
such a finger, these begin some
its creeping creeping aggression on the edge
h4 then h5 then maybe in some
moment we want some get away h1 h3
same 3 translations which and in the end well
don't loosen up and trio if white doesn't
the badge is tied precisely to the weakness
these two pawns especially h4 and h5 by playing
where are you 34 can not even be equal to v
especially if we say imagine the same
black played himself a6 yes i five
get college 3 4 quite quite
a normal plan is already to strengthen positions
cover same 7 would be pretty nasty
the source of such problems and troubles
beat the king e7 went the maximum
anyway, or is it already an hour
clock lag or vice versa op op
year depending on how you approach
here questions but an hour from the clouds looking around for an hour
the difference is well
the rarest case of the Basque date played a role
and exactly what we talked about in the hall on
e3 played king e7 radiation one bye
no surprises
clothes 8, as I understand it, will be played
very difficult to be and another well
rather yes I'm here then here then
I'm so you stuffed there will be a choice here's some
responsible decision either walk there
knight c3 immediately that is, we are without land
with his own hand
it is necessary 8 then it is necessary to formulate, but the question
how easy it is for blacks to change
one couple think that two couples we are in
principle does not give a prism do not give on them
because then they are most likely
tissue nobody's me to be honest
probably like the idea to put
horse on t32 and bite because here
there white more or less has time for free
cocked black
not able to size 3mm let's put and
then get along measured dress 1 selling
answer on water ts3 need to follow the progress
to not be it as if you would not force us
kadett d 7 good will not be all check
where up to 7 martens are purged 5 somehow a little
I invite principle yes accept
an invitation to which I describe Ilyusha like this
it is necessary already about reducing on the other hand maybe
be not picked up
street 1st husband lost just because
what hangs on the pool I already have it here
that is, you have to devour us combi in e6
then
so not very happy with the people in the chat writes
I don't know what the new boring chess game is
it doesn't look like a boring it is
knitting needles dry but not boring it and not too
there are differences and plus all the same, well, you were yesterday
watch them yes even I don't run on
slate party in the recording at the end of the tour
yes yes it's two draws and even the way i
I would like to ask again is not necessary
walk behind you to see how how
it happens yes today much more
dry game than yesterday but firstly this
the party's still in nothing ended and not
guaranteed to end tomorrow especially
boring will play they obviously
people have claims directly
logistic long until tomorrow yes
of course, no one is your davos, we guessed it
while we guess many moves of this
the party definitely needs 8 we guessed it
and still I put on immediately kun d3
immediately no is it right he piled on me
one pair he takes off and the horse I think
all the same, it will go to the dendrite much more
looks natural on d3 than on
other fields well this but also means
antics the same clean and now realized
that if the blacks really want they can
clings immediately
immediately h5 will be able to expel a reasonable
just move and all h5 no no i don't think
so harmful not not not quite
it's not obvious that he's that bad and yes
then let's say the width is half a glass
Yes
Maxim thought but I don’t think that very much
for a long time because imagine what
you can still beat on 28 accidents pretty
it's hard, but here it is
probably you know enters some such
they are whole friendly, you need to get 8 here
here and lulled and how when exactly when u
rival much more time you
you start to doubt and check
to double-check such distrust of oneself but
it's quite simple here
grandfather 8 still knight d3 quickly yes well, and here
Black needs to choose a formation
For example, you need to decide for yourself
where we may not be immediately but in
basically where do we put the king on the dash
shoot of 6 is the first question and the second
the question is how do we react to
expansion attempt on the kingside
whether we meet exit h4 with move hp
b4 will also have to react to b4
I want to be lazy to bare, yes, if not
4 will have to somehow
somehow a6 a4 a4 is one of
may be the most concrete ideas
which would generally be in this position
because again, too, to spend mowing
say on the king at 6 we went b4 a6 a4 and
a5 almost never black to go
it’s impossible because the horse is a little in suspension
and somehow you need to respond to the idea
being 4 by 5 is not very honest, it's clear how
even
then you will understand yes yes yes a4 b5 interest
another one is that after 6 there is a move and 23
5 seconds more useful and booth you played
broke up with me and if things go well
marten 5 stupid how fathers can
because and immediately the principle is also on
wonder how i am
I finally react again refereeing a pawn
eat next turn is simple and
actually not about us so
arranged the figures that her as a whole and
protect not so lyah anaconda 4 i can
think about beating her
are found for everyone to enter to enter and there are three
times to crank my weapon I began to sleep
and would 3 to 6 blacks give and so I don't
I see how it can be prevented
because on the field up to 7 the rook will be up to 7
New King of Duties by 7 Riding
so what is required of us about what
undoubted, it seems to me that in principle
it is with this game against kanitsa 6
the king should rather try to put
need 6 they for how much is the problem 100
in that it will be necessary to constantly monitor
for some game the elephant to 10 is
most of the time before the king all the same
closer on reinforce chase 6 well and here
this is where we start with these questions.
ask will show or behold the king is gone from
given to Spitz most likely we go the same 4 and
if 6 then here, as it were, they took it
water alone is already a serious problem
most likely because they come on
same 5 and black absolutely packed with
two weaknesses are most likely the case
some of them will be taken away sooner or later
and if we are forced, though, then
White actively has an extra pawn, just the same
really an extra pawn on the board
because we will create that distant
Polina already win just eat you can
somehow try to create some kind of
contours cargo queen up to 48 rep
create start villains 8 but
extremely responsible decision
responsibly and because if then contra
I don't get along then we just party soon
probably lost everything, yes, for example, here
gave this a little 5 minutes to tactics
dave 8 h5 went some 4 and took
on and 5 a savchik king e5 dasha 25 times
it seems that yes and then she still comes
knives 5 very date looks just like you
statically got here specifically
gave up therefore
control will not be easy to create
but again, I repeat that they are neither
another move so far not forced to think
that cains is again specifically not now
expresses extinguished it seems to be 8
do we want to make a rook move would you not
is the income of the cavalry 5 actually
pretty nasty nasty like this
let's pass some 6 do not call
stupid but finally again fret would be 8
here beat a friend badly I don't see right
because it's not always always the same
tactics don't let us go b6 on the knight until
4 all the same only stronger
because with a check on the neighbor on the horse b4
I can until the patio 23 ask what it is you
do young man so wherever 8
getting a villain would be a goose yea and that's it
went here let's say two bo3
a question about water d1 dissatisfaction 8
this is the first thing i wanted to check
but it's kinda like black keep on
rests on the basis of this one
simple designs for the work of you but
went bo3 renewed menace combi to be 7
because if immediately combi bass then
obviously black
right away because they have
very active rook
well, that's the same slang term
gluttonous row
here black can go where 4 in response to
that I can go horse up to 3 and since
Evgeny Miroshnichenko just pointed out
but the way chess works is why i
made what the [ __ ] would you come back 6 for
neck and thus roughly speaking
look here we have the current position
here it is and here we have this position
in which we played 2 b3 move to move 23
not harmful drove the ladies to 8 by 8 and
white move and well let's go here to be fishing
like version
I think it's pretty obvious that
white won some
there is no good time for something or maybe
don't care it's fundamentally appraisal
does not change it may well turn out to be black
anyway, somehow it keeps but I'm not happy
I think such balls of French mani for
hit so just in case less than half an hour
it remains for someone to wait until there
is playing here very quickly, that is
fires are probably dealing with enough
deep preparation and now that's what
you look more at this position and so we
I wanted to take it to b6, yes, but maybe
he can't most likely just push
on the right and now despite the simplification
despite what seems to be
one weakness
it is here that the maximum and difficulties than
also very hard to find
arrangement that would be completely
suited than here, that is, let's say if
by phone 1 to 6 also as illustrations i
I can just go okay 5 say
korolev 6b 4 a 6 0 4 strong even
as an illustration, even such a position
looks pretty expressive too hanging
pawn pool on the water until 7 I have here
chicken 5 to be given already
a pawn would be indulged by all some heavy
rather all blacks will lose this fingers
ears where such is not up to 7 step then street 7
will hit all this pawn center
the so-called that and yet here's the problem
probably knows these doubles and 5 and 6
what a but so very descriptive but
if we have the entire queenside
somehow changes and black
lose a pawn like this four by three
often deleting nice you say f g h
would stand yes this protection is protected by such
the horse is probably not quite a bit of a draw
but in layers, well, it can charm from a horse
medalists lost one of her pawns and
party to continue then most likely then
I think it's just the rays of my wife, although I'm all
time didn't win let's say an important game on
to whom and in the Moscow challenger 4 on 3
with rooks yet new
but I will not change, it is known that it is not the main
techie in the world
something look that still she we are so
and undecided yes we can't either
one comfortable move for him, therefore
I'm not surprised he's still
water sim undress water 7
well let's go say I don't want to 24
invited me to fit on the c bull line
I'll think about giving us up next turn
let's say at 6 you on except for a4 I already have
for example, there is such an opportunity here
here you start a pawn no, I'm not sure
that i need it now it's faster
draw
because either very much but then again
can continue water until 4 a5 q5
is located, yes, go king f6
in general, so far added 5 well there
dance and 5 don't do eyelashes 5 or
owner 4 again, I don’t see
asylum strap just fell apart the promise
dress up 4 looks like the same as him
I personally can't go why is he e5
will again strangle 1 to 7 will not be about
the number of checks of the end will be on the horse 5 rows
you take it I must go liquid
data should khadiji 5 well the last time
a pawn wins therefore probably because
that already like this growth and nevermind me
calmly 25 of them will be removed and 5 horses will not
it is very easy to imagine how we
made a couple of not very neat moves
black fell apart sample usually no one's
I think that if if you take some
quickly then I'm calmly satisfied on this
time before as for coming there probation
minutes forty-fifty maxim something
put on lose well yes it's unpleasant
and here is the sign, probably another
illustration as far as it can be
deceptive
deceptive viewing of chess with a computer
because well, I don’t know which one gives
evaluation of the computer even if small
let's say up objectively black holds on
if they do everything right but more importantly
us when in this party that's coming
there are 40 moves to be done carefully
fighting back yes without much active outline
games are, of course, very human
very unpleasant 25 minutes left 25
minutes before and well you can see in the face I think that
you don't have to be an expert
physiognomy to understand what is not
it's not easy yet you don't know yet
one interesting point, because
experience of ethers of numerous data before
third hours commentators doom do
Is there a break, won't we miss some
poked our 32 and often ends up with 2
hours go by but it's funny of course it is
it's very hard to remember something like this
it is of course clear that in some
moment at some point will it start
to think so that at the stage when something
will need to be calculated
choose between some
attractive options so far
really very very very
natural childbirth such things are not some
moment or he will start to understandably spend
your extra points even in such a 6
points system additional
points for taking you an hour and a half to
hours not honey honey accrued therefore
there is no doubt
surely at some point he
thinks but while thinking maxim
remains at not already 20 less than 25 minutes and
here's a close-up
position on the clock and of course not
unhappy extra from this not
fun maxim because he understands that
in general, he would understand this, they would have won
it was 1:20 for an hour but because he too
already received a number of
micro solutions are extremely fast which u
he would be eaten by time
if he didn't know the answers I say that is
let's say how many rooks to leave on the board
where exactly to lead the horse, let's say how much
quickly put it on 3 it's all well in
generally asked to do what he does
Lebanon, he would have thought, but so when he
in general, these three are cardio
here it is of course the situation for the player
black pieces are not nasty and plus I
given that we are always quite today
do not show in the picture I'm a little bit over
fiddled with the phone and discovered it for himself
chat so will be able too
react to but occurring in the chat
here they ask just thinking about this
the idea is probably not here, but in general here
if relatively speaking white puts a pawn
our 4th black I am also the leader of the shaitan and here
does the victim ever work on c6 i
I think that training spikes are not what are you talking about
said yesterday that positional victims
quality they go well when u
after that you still have one rook left
that is, so that whites can
be the quality of giving the last horse
the rook on the board they must eat like this
deference and three pawns or some
an incredible number of pawns or something
still here probably moisture should not immediately
enter here imagine this position
we're there six beat giving her page 5 of
hot overeating hard immediately taken
sent on well and black in response to this
let's go to the role in 6 let's say Vasya on the butt
Vasya
well, here it would not be very harmful
to have some figure on the board which
would control activity in thailand
how i drew a meaningless arrow but
after get along 2
well, these pawns do not reach and
well, maybe white won't lose
here but not to play to win
if you imagine
again, vodka is such a position that
squirrels contain two in black there
somewhere on the field and 8 then giving our dinner
and even better found need the same then
the quality would certainly be very
interesting and don't even drink with the knight on c6 he
supported getting dressed 2 and starting
move pawn bb-8 row 4 fight people
unofficial with Oleg Stankevich them
agree but would still like this and that
such an important rule that you need
always bear in mind that
quality sacrifices are good here's another one
another observation she doesn't have
attitudes towards this position are often
this kind of sacrifice quality passes
with multi-colored elephants it is necessary behind the scenes
we indicate White's dark-squared bishop which
somehow cements master nas
315 323 counter-sama bishop c8 is
Of course, such a situation is caricatured
such that's what let whites rob like
sticky just multiplying on c6 zagro
northern they can create more than one game with
everyone will fall down, yes, that's the horse against 1
rook without without 2 1 board rook monstrous
gains strength in such situations
king d6 chose maxim after all
lineup back to reality she
in fact, it seemed to me the main
which we discussed it was
the only one in which we did not see how
White immediately deals damage
insisted you find 4 all the way and me
it still seems to be right
the idea is to hint a little what is on the board
there is still there is still Egor Olevske hwang is not
queen centers only
that's the feeling of whether it's the first time he has
set the task to think unconcerned
but thoughtful up to A4 seems to me very
logical there are cavalry 5 which in
once again apparently forcing owned would
8 that is, maybe he is thinking about it
to start with cavalry 5 and after that
already make some useful move because
that we again put a little in
additional parterre than yes but on the other
hand now
figurines of their own as if boldly
went here from 400 here went h4 and h5
yes i am increasing them 8 space
this sell these means more sense
mean mean say variant h5 same 4
yes because the rook is temporarily at least
Least tied to and at 4 you calmly
depart reverse do not go and resume
threat tip and 5 which we constantly
then we say 15 checks or 4 checks if
he must root put back
it turns out we played in position h2h 4 and
black suddenly for some reason laid get8.ru
actually 8
so turning the tip of the water 8 she in
in general, it is interesting here for white
sheet
that is, if the authorities start
ponder here in the position after
move made king to 6 then
really comes to mind
maybe it's not stupid to take away like
there looks like a cauldron sky 8 strictly unity
here at all in the harbor because we
attacked with the genre would again be some kind of
go and we just start collecting 44
you immediately 11 miners danina would
446 and then up to 86 he's all there
falling apart takeoff don't pull like this like this
you can’t go under water in 8 now some
here is a useful move here is h4 don't know
maybe you can name useful code on
23 but i like how i like it
it is less obvious that white needs a 3rd
like here h4 and h5 it seems to me it's always
always the thing that owes us
wonder if we
a holiday that is always with you or h5
so just grab some more
some kind of space on
kingside and create
additional cause for concern
yes indeed black but not yet
done and not nice to play position
until these moves are made
or he thinks listen to the end, but still here with
Russian party
I still regret that, well, that's it
this option was chosen by them that's it
the most knight f6 which played in the match
Fabiana because there there he is exactly
one might well ask the question
some sharp but again the question is what
I meant nakamura-kun up to 70 and
76 is also to refuse what he meant
exactly the same move c34 there is the right moment
who did who did arsan before
sweeping away curly farewell for the following
five to ten moves given that
nakamura showed from 6 to 5 is impossible
exclude that and finally part too
demonstrated today some sort of semi
check i'm even check it's real
I can't name it well because
not a task here today
yes with you she is so cultured enough
all the figures have changed for those who us
listens I think everyone has already heard that and
chairs again city sleep all here but
because we we we live in the basement in
the basement is the so-called kim site dai
for such a place for breakfasts basically
although of course it is possible there and not only
have breakfast eat but mostly people
finally eat eat breakfast and
it is felt that they do not open though
would, in theory, should already be
some time open but so
because the chair just started to move
now you can not open something at 10
today to know is contagious yes somehow
belated shot down strange that so not not
right away it started so good amazing
and on the left he is something else and what else
codes can in principle
name 0 to that is, with the king you need 6
it seems to me that putting the head on 4
somehow looks even here
probably never will be
stifled indeed to play b4
the question is whether they can not
Q&A can not can by 4 us
can black b5 bet as soon as
the horse is protected maybe because
again, it will get better 5 there are 10 like a
there is even take and yes yes and here you can
yawn vladimir yes it's cute [ __ ]
55 again today we feel like in
familiar form
principle gave wherever 8 would follow I think
that you scatter extra floor to floor
maxim minutes no chase actually
let's compare this conversation which
in August we are with you, even just me too
created a mouth, taking into account the delay of this 30
seconds of autumn
for 29 seconds, maxim has the right to think
even on over the only move on
Shah rules this domain is even possible
must yes because it's time not
accumulates a total of at least or 8 already on
board and now here I am waiting for the move h2h 4
but is it possible that he has some other
opinion on this matter, we can find out right now
be exactly the assumption of the knight on c5 and
3-bet
you can start some a3 well, let's say
four dopas at once until the lining, but a3
if black like that we would 4 so we will ship
check with d1
and yes, it could be
grandmas such yet go and 23 if
black at home you are absolutely right that as much as 4
still we play but it's like
additional idea andrey suppose
h4 yes, well, three but most likely I think
that the expression generally go again because
what if
a3 a5 and that's long enough for us
delay immediately
b2b 400 we need such a process in such a process
of this configuration, most likely all the works
almost go definitely need to come back
gotta smoke up 3 yeah and here they are looking for
breathable you yourself would break the ball 554
there to approach therefore h4 proper and
plays levon this move has almost always been
it turned out to be useful to us not only
it's so easy to make a move with black because
there again is someone 7 again on k
on the queenside such a prophylactic
again there is here again yes again outcome
again as a translation into Russian
endless jokes of my colleague she
gustafsson bifa revealing but that's how who
he is the main engine in the masses
this joke of a simple idea to
h4 what an incredibly unpleasant position
actually from the first place probably
from a human point of view
and abildine I'm afraid that yes I think that and
objective not no fountain to be honest I
I will be very surprised if the computer
counting no problem, no problem at all
no it can't be yes the question is what
estimate yes and let's say these numbers they can
be even convey expresses objective
the assessment is not conveyed by the depressive
knew how many times which side you are
black looks at this position
some kind of hopelessness, yes, because
no figure has any active
active plans before you can go knight d4 and
at the same time you perfectly understand the answer to
horse d3 will have to medium will have to
finally put one figure
humanly people, too, not to mention
the fact that there is someone else in 4
how can you turn out yes probably then
you're coming back you're wrong
sad but I don't know because there in
the answer to this most likely comes out f5 before
dam already put before the question whether you want
you give me absolutely phenomenal and
field and 4 for the knight and then 4 and
like an attack on the Corolla just go and know
for the horse, whether for the king or for the king before
or you can go say when 4 is the answer
what else will they do here in some
editorial about nothing to beat on and 6 sections
money we don't have to 2 split on and 6 i
this is what I was planning, I think
king and 6 years old seven positions can
match close hopeless this if
I'm already overestimating how much this is
well, a vile position, let's say 4 later
5 [ __ ] 3 bed same 4
nasty finger but maybe possible on
them i so far make some move 8 up
the threads of the rook keeper would, other things being equal,
would try to beat sergey avoided completely
that's all the same so broken
returning doctor 0 to 3 panda 3
forces the cavalry to simply enter 6 because
what combi 35 is now
the most important so far went from 45 to and asked
that in the water until 8 we went to the mountain of the goal
would own 8 and 5 2 0 one more pawn yes yes
no he owns 87 us cut of course I
what should i really stand for
somewhere around seven or eight and everything that is can
be like nothing it looks like
pathological but our 4 may have
meaning to make this swing a horse
faster that seems to be 2 tons with what you need
launch the rook release the rook by
opportunities we invite repetition
after of course such a question should or
whites can still go to her
suspenders me ball immediately go well here
question can not go out b6 now candy
3 to the end
6 well, start moving there b4
let's say this
a6
that is, if that's me, I yawned
obsess hold lucinda eases or
4 4 hold on lag h5 but because you suppressed
black moves approximately 0 pieces
a new figure, that is, you will find
villains 606
beijing pass heavy see fingers at black
and the only thing that speaks in favor of
out and black chances of a draw here is that
that her, of course, like this canned food
It's not easy to open a jar
still [ __ ] just about what is very
bad with coordination and no matter how
solved structural problems scientists but
nevertheless the classical rule of two
weakness has not yet been canceled
so that's exactly what we're talking about
we move a pawn and that a pawn b somehow
trying to pick open to find yes more expensive
weak you will go to some second object
and then it will be possible to have them all
rules to pull apart using these two
weaknesses
so well, you don’t have three, like here I am
would fall like this 4 no we can't yet
I still can't at least 4 he means
on 3 it's just not on a6 but on 6 it's not
can feel atride b6
so wait, but I tried that I didn’t
such did not try all this when already how
off and nonsense
both can just be this this this
maybe there is hope for blacks and bbc bc
cinnamon 6 and rook on b3 and suddenly we have
have a good figure 1
but really good
I don’t know there is hope earthly compass
wait, I don't really believe it anymore
now I thought we'd see you dip well
difficulty to describe what's just back on
c6 he wants to go though everything happens
blink he also become on grope 63
recently, but here we will add taken away
he and Tikhonov have a finger again a4 b5 , but
it's something like it's artificial
absolutely but not on brave and
a second firmly no but can not
clearly he will disappear there because we are not
we can never go well 87 just
threatens b4 sense in this position in this
positions threatened to be life by 4 horse
just lose no me two can't
be called photo 3
why could he cause the hotel to move strange
the solution looks like a complete help
remember my idea was to play from either 4
a month it will turn out a3 the horse would leave 4 cities
that I'm at a loss which was not
why decided to bottle the wish happened
we also water the layer chance to 1, bringing it to
1 is coming
very very not out of my idea
some up to what for those you too but me
still bet on what he wants
bassem b6 play a3 b6 i.e. up to 36 and
6 well, now I'm taking the horse
probably radio 1 before a beat and rook there
beat and say baby 8 here's some though
there would be a semblance of activation, that's how it is
but at least it looks like
some thought and moreover it looks like
what he did yesterday where he is too
found an opportunity to reset the request
materials step up kitchen 2
some move raised well you wait for sure
unearthly
I can't see and I can see this yes
me 2 before the rook one king not well three
b6
so what if we drove the cognac
Favor 3 is a huge achievement for
whites are obviously completely black
defensively we have to go for some
there inside the tubes shingon cavalry 66 dan
Black achieved a lot in this
because that's all but let's stand no we
no matter how worse we are already falling and up
end bye yes yes this is generally the general
place in general common place mother dear
so here you drop I forbid them not
speak publicly, usurp my right
on a break and it's stuffy otherwise we just don't have
it will be possible to go to the top a couple of moves
Barcino will start such enough
serious time trouble now Aquarius thinks
and I think that he will be forced here
think deeply
because
suddenly they put specific
problems of course the last such nails
back really they followed
sticky theater on the previous move you need
was to change the move of the knight again turn on a3
a5 butt lifts like this yes maybe
for this it was necessary to understand that our 4
there is this enchanting perfect idea
scania twice took a horse and which
Of course, it doesn't come to mind right away.
this chalk needs to be protected from this
certainly extremely resourceful
resourceful defensive chess player and on
this note yes really let's
take a 10 minute break somewhere and
after that, most likely considering
we will look at the state of affairs on the clock
this guy to the end to the end or to
end of the first control stay with
us issuing a break after all already
brewing dan we'll be back we'll be back minutes
ten
[music]
flowers from
dm sa a yu know-how mandate
and here is this shopper
by dose you him
new that part of this other case horizont
or a group and kasbah finances will get
through
and a whole centimeter he went there let's go
here and there white pore well, again, not
kim jaejoon himself
she's gone gas trodding the street high
to be
from half life insurance and plays antigen
your disk start line
yuri nicole most steaks i
handy scales zation and five would say paul
konov withers cognitive facts so now
lawrence does not have this work valuable
loves a match match but the fans sheathe an hour
lakers impedance
break does one that's my
jump him to get set out i do get
some to hear is loves bien and perks
I won’t drink myself until the valley
my quality of life with a pole
downhill is noisy
describe play
[music]
apple store
he was his yuri
using the mouse not captain alexander
to helps
100 ask him on the volume of walking the
side this frequency from classic solution
with what smiley andrey kaikov
and throw steel miles per hour and alloise
ran world can be polite and handbag hour
thank you so much
million play pool game and helping haiti
this book and she's still repairing it
continue having a sen menim han deuc soo
mi talking about astana gap ann bolton
she blocks for the way to me to go grabbed
no one called the owl
surfer we escape from under the brush
site even ball
revealed the music play
test slide elvish he
and who they like did not suffer Armavir
seascape zariss site and ash from explo
and bike
[music]
well
too
[music]
now I'm folding
flash
online online
hour
we are now
les enfants
enough like the world
walls city club is a world of tanks in
such as a single phase x-art alpha
or goal reflex reported per hour art and
design whom i exhibitions in man play
music in a goal is to watch as all of
time is on stump become a left tiny love
you give up and
overalls now you and any of my pools
now who from conversations with keyless start
[music]
what friends return to live
second day of the semi-finals one game
us ended in a sense not
having time to start but in the second enough
an interesting event and I think that's all
arguments about how boring the game is
grandmaster will now be dispelled not
not very boring they are played he yes and
For now, one can only hope that
and on and on everything in the classical part in
this tournament will continue the same way
like the first two days before the nakamura party
caravan they are not to say very much
captured the imagination of chess
amateur but very interesting squirt
collect lemon with maxim and from either 6
as expected already worth it come on here's how
let's say the official position on
we will put the board with which in the party until
a2 a3 bassem b6 played that is, it's us
guessed it and during the break there us
a little hint to what really
in fact, what are the possibilities before and after to
she's 6 i have two which is undoubtedly
the center line which actually
he and feeds now properly assess
there is owner move 2 which i started
look but I don't understand what the idea is
and the idea is ours can go b3 and
18 clear income completely
prophylactically which controls everything
fields of invasion in business are just superfluous
a pawn turns out well, and not quite
just an extra pawn you can do on it
some meaningful intermediate move and
I don't know which one to choose
h5 let's say rook 218 and still
will have to try somehow
neutralize the activity of this water
king d2 to king 2 say mine
and here there is, as it were, a fork
bring the king somewhere ahead
then it will be necessary to constantly consider
Contra Hero Bound To Go Youth 1
or you can still move the king c1
yes maybe a king for one let's say a cat
for which our
english friends here let's say rook
b2 so that then move the king c2
but let's say the positions I'm in response to this
went to the role at 6
on whom edouard went back on to 8 and
I want to know how we
coming out of the corner here white
she is something that is still not
just young cubes 6 time
natural on the edge played
whether he considered obviously any of these
options yes yes and now I want to confirm
for a second that in the chat of our channel
this oil is both daily and Peter the last
channel chat message while dresses one
went did not go and I alone played him this
position we considered more
more encouraging for black rook
one cheese on carpet 6 beta 2 and already
Naturally get along messing revealed and
expected here is a little levon
I would say that it releases in this way
this position seemed to me closer to a draw
our role is d2 something king 2 obviously
there will be a cheese tree on the water until 8
table 2, as I understand it, yes, we'll see
Now how does he feel about it?
role 2 to owner 8 back I'm going
aspic 80 b4
and a4 what on 4 is 3 i was 123 this is here
a couple of moves and it's just nothing
renders, although wait a minute, but here we are
Us White Life Old Man King Well done 8
then until the move until the hot bird allegedly 4 we
let's go yes you 4 go baby 3 come on
put b5 I'm trying to understand there is no point
some make on see no other move
maybe b3 bottrill dressed edward
rila girls that because you sweat
smoke, that is, there is such a here and
black here is not in time at all a draw was
if b5 was covered again
in both 4 yes it's certainly not in time
before b3 b3 it is lebanon game that's it on
actually the same position
the one we discussed after getting dressed
2 for 3 but most likely a little bit white
behind
at the pace if we say there we are
considered the position in which here
kb
yes, it's just apparently all white there
behind because in that version we have
there was such a position and the move of white
and now we have this position and
Black's move and it's clear that this is our 5
completely empty instead of black
they will try to walk, for example, they will get along
three stages puts asian posing ok
one because you called on the stove
it may not be clear which is stronger
can be similar to water p1 paste
you can move a pawn b yes by the way it
absolutely wrong is one more
natural no background hound 3
again hinting at what is
counterplay associated with the move youth 1 and
plus how right absolutely evgeny
said idea fret would one would 4 fret b3's
the answer to how to expand the perimeter by 3 a
it's already there already white it's just hard
will do anything at all
so listening to that white to him
what to do maybe what to do
there is one of the plans to run the king on
same 3 to defend securely royal
flank of some point throw
queen and run where it moves on
return also yes how to tell the king in
2 to suppose as an illustration to the king
two side
king same 3 and beyond at some point
try to sweat dress 2 go at all but
the problem with this plan is that
let's say here we go now
a little or even maybe a
korolev is yours but dress up 2
there is a move king dashi and even so which
temporarily at least closed
absolutely all the fields somewhere you bring down roles 6
pirlo grandfather 8 radio 3 pawns equally i
after all, why did you choose a game
amount of time because I still
not on the seventh row and not attacked not ours
what we can't protect
the owner is one actually maxim and walks
but still it is necessary, again, it is necessary to say an important
enough thing about the difference let's say here
fingers that spend hours on the board and this one
position which was 8 moves ago and
maxim would mark 20 minutes at 16
year this position was no scholars at all
no game outline
must be passively protected against
an enemy who will gradually
amplify create camille create
minor threats before while current
position, again, we are not at all
we affirm that black and necessarily
save
I'm far from sure about this but play
its generally much easier than that
because you have clear guidelines
you understand that you need constantly
cling to some kind of foot create
when
did he make grandfather's numbers 2 what is it
all call come on move it seems pretty to me
natural he wants the h1 rook just
run yours where then but why
fret h1 tile tune would they like we
want to go i think water up to 3 and step by 2
no worries why are we slowly
let's flow here I'm talking about completely
forgot to move king f1 i want to go may
be a 42 . I'm here if 5 say and
drive probably that's what we go to 5
or from and because he is so I thought that
pretty reasonable u b3 b4's ice drift
four on up
after all, the pawn of the 3rd feather is protected
while on reaching the data of whom not
bring yes well, and here, too, here we are
we balk at the question say the back door of the rook
and two let's say the king is one black
walks h5 start again somehow yes
here it’s just araks again
parsed down to the kingside here
How realistic are White's chances for
draw outline what I wanted
to talk about how white this
position winning actually rise
chance it's good get along 3 on but people
for 6 pd-4
me more well this is just this
something is disturbing because I know
February
discard our old ate and overtake by 7
november to 6 hard to imagine
so that the whites are not ahead in this
potential arms race so
then the problem is why we are serious
still but once again
it became easier for them to play and plus
again, here is the poetics that we discussed
maybe black people should be here
at what point can we do this to
can not give White this arrangement in any way
which
in general, the problem is what, well, as if
black could play b5 and white
would go shorter one black would go
again yes it would be certain
achievement then of course position would with
more likely to hold because
what could be from fixing walking
looked out for gear a1 and yes, here he goes
rook one i actually wanted to ask
rook one will you go a4 and on to move
a pawn or something, and now let's say
go rook 3 while husband putting water down
from 3 building 1
I don't know, let's say rook bo1 divided 1
v2 korolev one have go a6 before people
died 5 inches become a pawn for deduction then
you need exactly this position which you are ready
that described and and case try to get yes
well let's play king anyway
I'll have to, I'm thinking of including the move h5
but again, let's say black can always
where do you start with h5 yes here would be
more diagrams like that we should here
kolev one acceptable 6 king waiting for both
5 we can ignore this request
be I think actually right
probably it is ignored by whites or not
so that there is still a pawn alive, well, because
she she is lost but in response to this we
we develop some frenzied activity
a knife, that is, for activity, does nothing
leads frantic activity while here as
where is cooper where is the evidence that
four by three won by pawn alien yes
that's why actually that's yes it's fingers
own your queens 1st have already reached and
[music]
Maxim will choose here I think
exactly between the moves a6 h5
since a 65 and k which is very important
resources by creating some object
for an interview on the queenside and h5
6 is, in principle, an arrangement that
allows you to control the situation
on royal don't let white create
too rain, but why and that's all the same
gave up a pawn and let's try well
Of course they shouldn't have checked it.
there road bbb
well, like in some kind of sauce
cook something yes, for example, cheats
maybe so, because
allow the boss's tongue yes yes here you are
you want to go and go
it is very important always in these fingers
idea and specifically here it seems to me
just wrong to do nothing
take away a pawn just well, exactly, yes, sort of
simulate a game to win in some
here is such a position I'm afraid that it will not
very convincing what color to change
none of the good things that she sent either 8
no advice yes of course yes yes well
yes yes please please
really black must exactly sage
5 start me on supplementing also not and
no more chances
grab some space
royal and actually h5 e5 yes
even for the future that on occasion and 4 by 3
so much easier to keep than with white
pawn still found yes, well, I think
that doesn't pay much and
immediate 76 I don't know what exactly we are
we achieve then again took took zhora
Kolya needs to be modestly ev1 hardly
we strongly claim some kind of victory
yes, because well, here are some options
get along 3 king to 6th baby 8
she's too slow to the point that
i would like 4 showing beg to be four
or is there some kind of nearby there are six
again, do not pull apart already the king is not
I am glad of anguish from these two pawns without
some extra entertainment
we are actually discussing a rook trap with
material equality which, although not
maybe I'm wrong I would sow water 316
king is 5-6
roles in 4n another thing that bark
becomes very active not worse at all
but I'm leading this pawn to see if the pawn has been eaten
but I ate a pawn all the same here in fact
In fact, we will talk about three results for an hour
well then I still chose a6 maxim
Let's not blame him for that either.
there was no doubt
idea to start them at our 7 5 but also in
in general, on the other hand, humanly
if we talk about where we are now I
I'm sorry, I just wanted to
all
bring it to a divine sight it's got me off
working with databases
reflex desire to make home
the line that was in the party I therefore
ceiling is the number of clicks per 1 pair
hammer line don't get rid of old habits
what I wanted to say on the thirty-sixth
in a relatively colorful year he has them
not time trouble but he doesn't have much
time
a6 for 5 black will always need h5
may turn out to be a mistake and man me
seems reflexively always chooses
less less answer obliging give no
obliging such a situation, since
the probability of not guessing with move a6 is
still lower than the probability of not guessing
sell hp
any chances to keep both pawns on
there is no queen at all it is possible in
some slow break
iron get along 3 on occasion maybe
be really the king until 7 we find
to not even give a chance
opponents axis though then we can't
pull out and reduce 5 i.e. might
so so and go somehow here h4 and h5
and on b5 now it's time to break away
No
here probably some kind of well begins
something quite possible, well, yes, again
need to immediately balance even in this
positions probably black can still
spin try body here m
perhaps from 66 for through and 6 through 666 a
anyway, this position turns out to be on him
get away 5 lose it's easy
lose
lost on e5 rook moves behind
there a little on the same two very even it
risky, that's just what they knew
maybe you really need to do
immediately in too we have already tried though
h5 b5 beat beat and dress 3 well then how
times black has time to go to 4 that is this
if
if you try to break away through line c
owns it must be done while the pawn is still
stands on b6
that is, he and in this sense h5 does not
helped apparently we then probably all
equal to mosh pit yes wait owner 3
once again that is the threat of the owner 6
great importance america kind 6 here and there
I don't have much choice I would not
I like well, first of all, it does not cure anything
I can take and give check Yes, that is, I still
I will start a check, I will force it to move to f7 and here in
this position will think white me in
first there is this 4 by 3 which given
that pawn e5 but we suspect that he
draws but we are less confident than in
the usual 4 by 3 and plus there is
additional possible yes a b a b here
laden which has just been won
chorerel pathology becomes delayed
would no way fail somehow
twist have to move b4 up
alodi will stop behind white just
gradually pull out gently
kingside
usually such comrades are hopeless
of course, of course, there are
exceptions on any name steal one
walks does not contact levon with everyone
these things to
bye gone bye bye by 15
everyone has not had time the same thing has he already
can't get because well done
three he will always have maxim always
will answer b5 by 4 some thoughts
this can be important such a turning point
the moment was now spent in the party where
he deprived himself of some
number of additional additional
possibilities yes we don't know right
it was wrong but back and no longer
return so to speak such you know what
try try to collect owner 3
let's just say I don't know why the king is up to 6
we see let's say yes and not wash it off really
actually received
important bb don't go up to too if it costs
3 then I definitely go to 544 go and
if you start owner 3.4 me
it seems scary check I take only how
minimum and white strongly having a need
nothing more no more half soon
did nothing more than 6 check b3
driving we really we have to pretty
a lot of pace burn on getting king
4 it is necessary and yes and it can be very
bad edition turns out further given
another ball king can and to cycle it
the truth is very but it may turn out
very bad yes h5 same three and then look
they kept him korolev i 2 went there I'll show you
two same 3 clothes 2
go up really package 4 h5
a huge number of questions in black
will
as if in photo 6 how whites go to
h5 and h6 .
how we respond to a threat threat 6 1
the most important question which is here because
probably worth mentioning too
studied its time here is the end of htm
h6 if black their lunite f4 was taken to the role in
4 such a structure, that is, a pawn to her there
same 4 well, and the answers I don’t know how to pace
no, I know for sure that if it is already 4
there is a king on f5 conditionally you win something
not surprised pawn is introduced yes and 6 king
passes on the same 6 somehow it's there with some
tons with them but overall won
how different is the different position here
here, if there are any, they may be
slow
well, in general, yes, here is such a position
the nasty which keeps us closer
and lean closer to what can
turn out but then again it's we would go 4
still let's go king to 60 to 6
Yes, this is where I actually went
like you wanted picked up and walked owners 8
took took no I have to wait
probably approaches of four went until h5
well delivered will have to pick up the autumn
went for this one went for this other
the rule is probably a draw
I would not even paint alone, maybe for
yellow yes would go 3rd get along 723 also
it's also the way draw is it sadness is it
will the white man finish the job
or white they are 8 water in the middle of the bass
yeah i mean it's forced to run at first
yes, black is definitely out of danger here
fire on
because the king is too far
we can then step up the postal 3 game
the pencils
how
Yes
really good day came up
maxim and that's it by calling a pawn to
call move a4 and a6 b5 b4 invite
weakness on b3
Yes, to the place here and what matters is exactly what
he does it
as if in this construction
because although it may actually be
if you remember where I had it all I was
That's why I tried to keep
other options yes we tried here in
this coming b5 instead of leaving pawns
on a3 b3 then like this
design black can never
hold again and respectively white
piglets feel much calmer
chan stages up direct counterplay now
we can crawl knife king 3 on this
our walk woman or 3 of 4 yeah
well drag here of course you at least this
a huge mistake must of course hoarsely
dead 2
a4 a6 and it turns out well, not you losing
what kind of pace you also give the machine
arranged to tear off immediately gave
get dressed in the afternoon for 6 will work out 8
maxim content where some win
time maxim did the same with
much much clearer and without losing themes
more effectively lose up to be heard
this is the game advantage of Aronian
I would say both parties seem to
may not result in predominantly
we won't do it on the scoreboard
far-reaching conclusions about this position I
as always happens when I
forced to comment on lodey spire
I'm very delayed until I feel
charlatans yes but the chances of nothing
decent I think that I will decide on this
assertion the chances of a draw are decent
Yes, but especially in connection with the threat that
you discovered when the pawn itself is on b4
black is not passively waiting to threaten to play
just get along two camps become
trip features if white rips off
the pawn fell away 2 and the pawn on f3 still
starts to lead
and here, for comparison, if we
started with get along 3 here not previous
the gift missed this moment and we
watched the option king up to 6 and here I am
here h5 bo5 would cost 80 b3 rook
already here by the way, too, probably
and also the king on f1 is completely different
here the rook are we just for shelters
frown
we just take and that's why
here it seemed scary to me
because we lost the same pawn 7 and u
the king is closer to pawn b and the pawn is still on
casino would 4 turn king same 15 me
this seems to make things a lot easier
makes life very easy for us and again
I don't want to take responsibility
says that the king is one serious
mistake, but it feels like this
school he can be the king of the same one
make the first move in the game with your hand
just wanted to say what could be
lulled was such a development of events throughout
and now he's on the clock but probably worth it
just a little more time
spend to delve into something to figure out
and and and how often is up to 11 move on
which may have to be turned
attention to think a little longer, maybe he
might cost him
some important pace in this shootin
with no doubt countable there by voitys here
as if by one understanding most likely
will not get off
understanding think that one of our front
much better than mine but
here's king one doesn't seem to make sense
given that the clock was 1:10 to be
moment for about 4 trips on 4
it was even possible to dotan for five moves
invest up to dachshund seriously here sit down
and indeed the coming years
determined perhaps yes somehow flew
it's not someone's at all, is it at all or
grenade do you something between yes and on
a second while lebanon thinks curious
a thing that we also did not have time to air
discuss but me she she came to me
well, I somehow threw my head away, here is Alex
Stankevich says that he tried
Calculate what's going on by salute 7
king 6th says he was considering the idea
first go rook exchange 7 and maybe
even more subtle idea to go king
Gram on for had to keep a horse
he was still threatened with death g7 anal
18 step we may go for the horse
king and compared to what
going in the party voice with a very
relatively active fritters
get along with me, too, it seemed kind of
interesting but we went on a break and then
already before already the players fled from there as
and now the lemon makes a move that
here he determines what exactly he is
Oriented here played clothes 8
just under hunting not stupid note 4 by 3
get along halogen he secured 4 on 3 7
where would be three fret a8 and if we would both
rook 2 move rook 2 then the question is if
won
what he provided then can nothing
provided I don't see how we can
you can eat something white here
put rook 8 radio 7
play 4 on 4 before pretending to be a pawn
I loved the case, I think that's nothing I
I think that draw bridges one but two and
prevent white from organizing some
checkpoints to torment probably you can
a little bit than to go immediately hp because
if if allow h5 and h6 then completely
draw such an assumption therefore we
we go h5 here and then we try
king h2k what to do their weapon what or
before
and what then may be sux vangi
or water pool big mine in luck
editions
but it is also important that he is in general after
guessing already decided that the chances in the
slow game he has no
and plus, he probably tries everything
yet again such a psychological
famous thing to try to put
maximum number of questions
good king yes yes yes 1 contact now
to provoke some more
impulsive decision there, yes, and again
if you take this this 4 by 3 then this
edition is much better than that and which you
they said because mura is beauty to everyone
h5 can support mish why don't you
tried to get along with you 3 king to 6
change clothes in the lower floor according to the meaning
a similar thing, well, there can give audio
be he didn't want to pace him to hit yes yes
but here just here just a woman with
8th baladeo 2 is played to and that's it
just 18 came for the royals for us
comes behind the king's flanks here yes
there is a feeling that he is again
maybe he hasn't been right for weeks
worth but maybe he kanesh evil because
what is really important here
probably the difference between the king on e7
the king on me is not here for everyone, but at least
additional question would be asked
would force this 4 over yes here
sleep well and gently it's absolutely on
water up to 8 has already been played by a woman with a maxim
the matter naturally should be as it were
leave a pawn to black
somehow strange rook 2 will go here
we introduce unusual fundamentally nothing
does it change I don't see why give white
this is photo 5
what exactly are we trying to achieve by giving
white additional features i don't
I understand audi a2 and I don't see how it's possible
some checks to confuse therefore
about that's the finger which we
said we'll get most likely rook 8
and 7 or maybe 86 would be okay
something like where would 6 catch up with the king
yes it's not included h5 suppose
turned on h5 tried to bring the king
somewhere in the area of ​​\u200b\u200bthe field g4 move this
maybe it's because it's because she
will play apparently of course it will
you can't really play it
neatly playing probably one of the questions
should i play 6 here suppose with
black play well oh well i'm the one i'm
such we that after 6 big problems yeah
here especially in part again having tried
groin pawn you
a6 threatens to step on 7 to if they love
a6 you are good with them, you managed one
grab and if we unhook one here, then
we have
huge chances of winning
probably move can be h5 and h6 or h5
the same 6 another 6 somehow does not happen to us
like a 7 hat or pretty scary
h6 followed by already there
lost also thought keep it 7 7 lucky
moments the pawn e5 can be lost in this way
way
yes that is the position you still
but they she plays radio 2 played on
blackboard and now again at the lemon
there is a choice he can put the rook on 7
can put laden b6 both of these
sequels have their pluses with mine
August to 6
more successfully let's go more actively
looks up
create some additional threats
what comes out of black 6
toyota then we would crawl where then here we are
crawled yes they went let's say 12 we
crawled they went again but went the same 3 in
report from behind while delivered
well, yes, at some point, but here I am already 8
you want this mysterious but tone
forces him to bet h6 for good
management and it is for this play and
we orient ourselves and will make h5 in it there is not
important to be also so believes that the pace is not
super important will go apparently eight times the water
now rook 4th fret former check to king
all h5 here actually on this one
stance or get out and he saw the tenant
something similar to what we have
I think for myself that what is strong here
critically, we again reached the 40th move
so for now what you see on the clock
added time because before
what will be satisfied with them someone should
completely use up 1 hour 40 but already
40 moves on the board
you know i'm really looking forward to it now
some kind of thoughts again, apparently from
maxim as soon as possible here is the position
which is again black on the diagram
must decide how exactly they
going to keep her yea yea yea for
start on you
black if they just start running away
pawn google data pawn by mind
lose a3
especially if atari though that's all
still on to role in 5 there is a boiler holding 1
and you have to walk like that, hold 2 and 5
in clothes 5th floor draw too we still help
them a little because we have more
active checkpoint but of course it's already
should be century clothing tags 5th 1st on
this they are about me don't jump this we don't
lost
but also on occasion, even without haste from
Vanya 3 will not lose where he is lying down
exactly what are you trying to do
achieve queens 6
line placements on f exactly
absolutely does not want queens 6
Hellas would be 8 we would give 8 it is not clear what
precisely shuffling yes on fret brio 4
rook big ball before rook shopa 6 king
and all this is all cool and understandable, well,
most likely all the same h4 and h5 because
let black bet from 6 h5
some strange decision obviously that
black is much more profitable to put
as much as 5 6 so that it doesn't happen that's it
the king's passage through
through our same 4 on so h5 I played and
here, hand it out
my interchanges look at what we already
looked yes that is some kind of passage in
passage on foot and it is not clear whether it leads
draws well, yes, of course, I would try with black
still pester although give a strong
Not by pestering out on the same 4's
you are already three and it will be necessary to allow or
f4u words famously really, again, if
sketchy i went 120 we went king
h2 wat is again a rook a6 a4 king h3o
3 already
and lower the rook one second so
sleep on water 12
and this is not a draw at all korolev 5131
sense mine king let's say autumn
gave a debit from Volodya byd f3 king of spades
rugia of 3 think it should be a draw
by meaning
cow 6 that is up to not at all
let well, yes, well, and we will say in response
let's go 7 suppose to
organize your pawn organize
your pawn mistake slept the same 7 for the king
I would like to have okay we are the man
than just talking about the philidor position
this is also not there, White gives a couple of checks before
shah shah goes and 5 and 5 are already on the general
darknet even afraid to lie to me yet
not 6 remove the pawn h Ivanovich and with that
hand the king had already so damn
hold on not then accordingly
no move white from white but even if well
like how she is here and again
demonstrated wall need somehow
sharjah i'm less than 8 became eight shah
in short, everyone to Russia, well, here we are
yes, it may be important that there is trouble on the line
Here again, imagine that
there are no pawns and here it seems like maybe I
lost because the king to 76 is here
it seems that you need it right there you need it
so that her line was not enough cells
us calmly not long enough but
of course if available
in the presence of pawns, even black is engaged in
him and do nonsense advanced
pawn right up to and even if white somehow
miraculously reach there should be enough to give
a pawn in the report for an e3 pawn less than 8 here
in fact, it is clear that they are not
they run because the pawn will be our 2
faster than the white pawn will be on and 7 and
blacks will have to
sense the whites I will need to digress
on this because we got a little carried away
and on the board yet it's fingers on
sixtieth year and this is which on
forty-fourth but nonetheless
some importance option which we
showed has practical
there but on the other hand what is black
there is a position one way or another will happen
sorry because what what here or him
or
or black can try to make
it's the fastest because I was walking
dead 2 then go rook one maybe
we can really check what will happen
the most direct yes and weather stop for
let's go white go king h 3 o 4 white
send the king of dreams this is you to be
here it is here and I'm just here d-thinking
must look spout.
it might be more accurate to go rook 6 because
that youth one we go do you
accordingly keep we called photo 2
and so hopeless because not to eat
pawn same hyundai h1
and I kind of have an idea, but the truth is also how much
it's a draw
you basement debit h5 king and 6
on I accidentally youth how are you 4
this is also nato not such a draw even before
again already rook h5 well, probably all the same
draw because even then I'm everything
time me shahlo gay 8 by when i
somehow rip the villains 5y good new
such a certain such nobody would like
yes, yes, in general, I would like it to be simpler
some do went until a6 again well
which does not fundamentally change
absolutely nothing changes without
pawn movements and he practically
sure loses so move her
it is necessary and with the move a6 again he is like he
makes obligatory not defined there
go ladis that and we anyway on
next move will have to decide
or it caught fire 6 2.0 h2 maybe not
wanna let's go by 4 ladies voice
it's true why endured well and well
want us just not good because
how we gon' attack now
pawn
now I actually came to and
won at 5
because from the 4th row and and he is an explanation
a lot of 3g will walk in time to you
you go to the role in 5 no but how the moves
here I get tired apparently with the king king e7 on
b2 back but it seems strong to me
improved version
well, let me stay, for example, for example
systems that we allowed here and at 4 I did not
I know whether this is good or bad, but there is
with such a position that is quite
it may turn out to be very good too, but this is in this
heavy may well be very
low again I miss a little
education to speak confidently
how much better or worse is it
comparison
but
well, in general, additional features
are given therefore probably it is possible and the king already
two or more of the practical
considerations if you think like that here
go im doing if we white choose
between king and rook 6 and suppose
that objectively there is no big difference
be there because it may be
it makes sense mbl give yourself the opportunity
think if he wants to put the ladder on
b4 good
you are probably right that there is not much difference
that is, we are talking about some kind of everything
equals ending yes where is the king's passage at
same 4 pawn exchange and black is forced
be a different teddy bear she's some kind and in a hurry
whites on some one of before beaten and behold
where White is required to the maximum
squeeze out of this position 3 on 3 with
weaknesses are not peaceful on the royal to survive
some most successful version and
hope that she was playing the feeling that
about this now exactly about this
now it's talking
yes it's interesting to watch
and he is still undecided
well, good 56 is actually important to me
6 and generally 1:50 absolutely nowhere to rush
and there is no reason
no reason to rush us to make a move
instantly
plant k.a.
but then it's not quite such a position well
I just remembered the same sync
field cup which we are with you
combined this victory carson
however, our murai is a little different
there was a structure and I'm not sure what is
some fundamental parallels because
that there was initially quite easy
a draw and then arose until only white
illuminated gatehouse our 5k penetrated
this party is unlikely in how we will
have
yes there was a pawn
scientists in that fingers were pawns e5 v6 and
same 5 against
and 4 3 salts are 4 and h5 like this
side 6 nobody was there so in
first there it's not right away
arise still nakamura 5 more before
nakamuru went why did 5 allowed 4 5
to a decision that was perfect
need not caused he could
calmly play by saved by saved bye
his pawn was alive 6 or where indicated
our mass and there the finger was held in
in general, it’s pretty calm that we will
move still waiting for decision yes but in
in principle, of course, you can move
suppose all the same, the beginning of 6 is where
Vladimir goes to one names 2 call
the difference seems to be that if we and
bet first on 2 we force white
apply for the same 3
how much does it change when
you compared just means if we do this
do not do it, we have such a position
2 and here we have whites 1 we went, but we don’t
Went to role in 5 owner shah and didn't
reduce necha eat also their pressed but
check wait checked this output
role play for h1 yes that's how they are
do not remember anything, we discussed here
shah and king of the south how simple is that
mercilessly me the whole question completely
open because the pawn is on and give a very
the weak king is very far from her
as if so far we have succeeded
perhaps this is the position if the rook
goes to 1 if she goes to 2
exit king h 2 so 4 king 4 a 3g 3
rook one king same 4 a2 and in this
positions on the king and but I'm already at 5 there
move owns us new appears
the opportunity to drive up yes it's us too
to see cause it's closer to
a draw of course if it's just apparently
call the same 3 useful wait again in
this fingers if we want we can play
the same position we there is a big difference
even but but plus to this we have
did not regret 1 important option to collect pawns
collect pawns f and same which are more likely
all this should lead to the reason
only I will order the position which
discussed that white try king and 6
go up
people chatting snickering says what if
broadcast only the resultant
broadcast party will have to let go
cancel let's not do it all the same
keep White's winning chances in this
party, although it is generally formulated
beautiful beautiful beauty wording not
we can refuse Oleg's data on the other
side on the other side yes let's go
then it can all end like this
weird passive a bit up defense
black and no one but let's remember then
what a clear resource I found your logger
drums passive position vodka is not a boyar
bye my 2
while we are waiting for a decision it should be in this
thumbs up idea by 4 from 3 to 6 wins
and 6 and here stone 2 is of course
demonstrate a clear understanding of
what is better passive defense of a position in
which seems like even while we have nothing
not particularly threatening or vice versa
without a clean and life without a clean pawn is the same
in a good way we gave up a healthy pawn, but
but we have active figures
there is something to strive for
maxim today as well as yesterday in general
demonstrates a very good understanding
how to properly protect unpleasant
chess position at some point a
transition to an initiative game which is
once
voyage and played yes, well, now again
an important moment probably in the game because
that the maxim must be chosen must be chosen
cage for get along we suppose bye
which, again, and the account is more accurate than all this
doing you to evoke the mmo genre
call yes and it’s definitely not useful
of course to say so, but
we assume that Vadya Vadya come on another
hand here I am 2 actual maxim walks
Yes
we need a penetration by the king through the same 4 yeah
because the king has no other plan
not king at all h2 come on again
move king h2o 4 king h3 from 35 and
ask who comments we are done
in such voiceovers
it's okay 4 no ideas at all
personal then it is not clear how we will
aspect pulled out uncle one yes and by
good, I didn’t have time to horror
fix a draw because mine
meaning
thoughts of even 4 actually had some
because play the same 5 and the same king
go through many here using
walking umbrella but it's too slow
for everything that Ukraine needs to be for this
field again so that it has a chance at
chances of realization yes yes therefore same 3
again rook one natural king
must go ahead otherwise we will never
fingers won't win king same 4 a 2 a 4
you can’t walk because there was a step on
first king 5 after strictly
the only move yes it looks like here
we proceed from the fact that this is more
a clear draw with something
Yes, and I can't see an example, I can't see any
wait, I look at one negative with a vanga
we can't build
how can I be king with them all though not
I think it's me somehow strong
confuse in this anechka this turn
pass studio 8 there king at 6 rook 7
you will go to the helm, collapsed and not
paying attention that I walk on these
youth and mongrel beetle will all such
own already had a role in 5 more
let's see this one here
yes'll 17 apparently knives 8 to king and 6
did not threaten the dress monad
lose with white roll king g6 yes and so
such an important moment yes it seems that
we created a mate threat in 1 move but how
often happens and there are odondo villains 3 on
actually not smoother either
lost but one dick with him shivana
rook 8 checkmate answer beta 8 is such a
general no max
well-known construction therefore owns from
Volodya bits, you are natural, as it were
in short four magician defeated victory not
consider cavalier 5 la holds 3
king e6 again if you want a king
on and on it's not very clear why
scientists still generally until eternity me
there went the same 6 ladies it seems to me
which I can quite comfortably say
it's a draw
already hold there is a king and 7
somehow you really want to say how it is
say how again it cost diani for 2
on b2 i was absolutely was saying the same
bottoms to my liking I was like black rook 6
would give shah
from the other side, but given that the line a y
we were taken away, so I'm a little worried, but
I think that objectively the final position
must hold a poop that owes you
something to help, including, of course, me
I think that even if we are completely
we play primitively with black, let's play here
that notorious bridge building
Belstat data owes such a number
take time between 1 and 4 which is simple
here is the guy at the ends will be and you with
somehow reminded hello
with let's say shorter than 7 and again connected
coherent speech as well as where 6 and 6 yes I
generally think they didn't make us a draw though
no hurry already probably don't do it yes
just king a6 and getting ready to fold
haste is probably not the point we go
here, relatively speaking, the rook is the same one yes
they go to role 8 because the beginning
what they want from life is not clear to us
we walk and one is seven we walk at all
pounding on just absolutely certainly yes
here I am shishak place orders all roles
everyone a second and give birth owns 6
I have to give a step on well you go
about our king dashi is not upset
king of dsm and this pro game because
Do you feel we have 5 top5 is not enough
star
usually it turns out that a lot of pace is not
enough of such a position, we will show everything
how to lose Volodya 3
in short four queens 63
check that he put me 2a yes just just
a horse is more expensive than 5 seconds on the fabric h and this
doesn't mean anything for some reason
definitely not a second
h4 now looking for that's funny that's that
it's funny exhale if that's if that's all
all the same, of course, yes, we are looking for victory and
sure that something or maybe it's just
and not an unwinnable position, I think so
hurts we we can't shoulder anywhere
push this king, I'm not in it
converges in moves moreover already on
chalkboard how to question about you already fingers
after we will return to confirm our
blaspheme
at least in this ending, yes, and here we are
most have already guessed this position
expenses well because we mentioned before
what he needs there effective 1:50 on
but White's chances of winning are other than this
transition to this position and that's it
has a choice between rook and fadina water h1
but it seems to me that he should go f1
the rook with a spire looks much less
obviously as
as not an immediate draw though
again, it's not hard for me to believe that
you can choose what you can choose this
nobody's position
it's real dangerous
not just dangerous as it should be
lost overslept on just here
Youth to us had an option given
five women is it or 5 f4 is possible
specifically here there are also 4 just panels but
and same 4 too because i'm kinda not sure
it's police holding rook 8 step 2 htm
18 faces owns 5 for 6 years and 6 is king
of 6 is an instruction for a pawn taken though
maybe it's just not someone's
objectively good and 7 you also need this
draw gave deev one actually plays
young people understand that we miss
bored so consider the move
rook h1 what's the water and the mayor's fadina
the strongest move but now it means
we will have on the board, well, it’s clear that
turn on the radio 7 step it never
mistake, I think that will suit you
step owners here the king will go on
it makes sense to go not to the same 8 but let's say to
I think it to everyone that we will say no 1738
what in general can be quite
a serious mistake because in this
breed 6 may upset may be
a serious problem that threatens mats is not
Will not the only one who owns a step want
on we got a completely different position
which I mentioned to Gordon allegedly as
theoretically won which we
do not want to receive therefore
come on 8 need dresses from Volodya f3
again, it is clear that you can beat
probably give two checks but still in
end up sing king e6 what's up
there is no parish because I suspect that
probably makes no sense of a move on keeps me
I don't know why everyone is so excited about
but even with him 6, let’s say you can’t lose
h5 king to 6 and down, that is, we will
but she's gone no for so long
will pass you didn't live with us it 2
related yes we have more stock
she probably goes through it gradually
im so many contra games will be organized
how gradually
and to the victories of the ears there, probably, or even completely
fool in the morning yes now now me
will now have to become hidden in front of her
sindo is there somewhere to understand the shah
king to 7 step to role 8 and now
went shorter than 6 and drove 6 7 to h5 here
by the way h5 dacha korolev 8 take a shot
the king lived and she sense here we are not
we know it's better or worse yes and 8
beat beat h4 need bad luck eat by
doesn't even own 3 king in 5 there like
talking to turn seven g4 speedy
winding up still unsuccessfully by
it seems that we see a reserve with scientists
have and
still need some precision
from from maxim but so in a good way rather
everything is located should not lose
so even under the fact that but you think in
this position say to this aqua
it means that he doesn’t seriously think
is there any difference between owning
check immediately to you then 2 if he is doing
no i dont see any
why not think about wagon time
and the trolley of the main I think that he is
thinks because maybe Kossky forge yes
yes here in the chat worries what happened to
a spectator who was always interested
your personal opinion is true
here says that we have some such
the club has already gathered at one o'clock and I remember everyone
one is the same nicer i feel it
I know well by my native conditionally
telling chat start 24 to where too already
have their regulars orbit two perfectly
without a check, but again, let's repeat this
exactly the same position the same question
tastes like it's the devil or now
exactly warps and 5 is exactly the king and now
again, the check is shorter than 8 positions, so she can
be even relatively speaking we're winning us
lived that we we had the same villain position
for two types we have oslo 90 is equal to the king
e6 then maybe king d66 go for
yourself risks want contains 5 that's just
went and therefore here it is necessary to run to the vein
went well for 66, this is of course
certainly
and strand welcome our our friend
Mikhail Savinov print
but yes yes days when it comes to us
classic classics in 960 i think that
need some rome wait it's not
today and not tomorrow again e5
just hit yes and 6 we sell shah from behind
as if nothing happened but
this one is very hard for me to believe we don't have
enough for us already 1 of ours were standing
hid role 5 before you king cut himself
that in those cases the king was not
cut the father was sick or the position of the philidor
you give the shah to the shah and the steps are already after the fact
Philidor police happened while called
grew decided and Dasha frail head to
seconds king e7 the only move if
we don't want to admit philidor bard well
and now they drove our urban
conditionally, the nose probably still came out of
cut off or even just went h-44
just went h4 to kovalev six again
they will bring the philidor by agreement with me
there is still the same standard operation with
philidor crossing if they want somehow
the king of his syntaq family will already be a pawn
our 2 through 2 chord is here in the chat
a person notes that he is not afraid to leave
your I logrov from behind the board gave no fear
because in fact it is an indication
hours to show that he has seconds, but they
already passed 1 control this after the fall
flag now I will be added now you
in 20 seconds you will see why
don't be afraid go behind the boards
hours its suddenly going to be a lot of time
let's get back to reality, really
reality will soon turn into something
that we don't suffer so we can wait
until the case comes and eats all the pawns but
yes, actually no lemon
jumped up and did not point out forensically but
there was no clock reading
cause for concern its current
position does not look
did not come current position looks like
looks like demand not black still not
they took the naive now I'll take it then I came
came killed if you don't want to in the next
time to start this option so well yes
I already have quite a few
you don't see it because you have
screen only my demo board
I still have it there
notation next to them and the product of our
how to say inflamed brain
a huge number of options that we
already shakhnaz evgeniy discussed their losing
a little bit sorry i'm so step on this
king livin sinu think the king is alive
here because any other field gives
the ability to threaten mate in 1 move
which is probably not given to whites
grounds
say if go now suggestive
queens 8 king and 662 actually somehow
so probably it's fingers and is played
potentially lost out of chickpeas again
must check after a chick to robert 6
how hopeless it is
suspicion that it may be hopeless
same role 8 therefore
well, here we are discussing the subtle
world difference king e6 king even 6
chooses to get out as a matter of fact
Eugene pointed out the correct ones and here we are
went same 6 immediately 60 and how to do
pretty simple not in my imagination
a6 thirst if if women stopped by 6 and step
makes it feel pretty simple
technical is not a miracle
let's wait what they think about this mvl
but again, honestly, I don’t really see it there
room for
fatal lungs get the country for
fatal mistake of another country and
no room for black fantasy
especially but again you can start
give shokhin then after 13 king and 6
we can't go the same 6k you the difference is
that so far we have an ideal rook
in order to create your own
passers to change the last non-pawn e
on the board so I will say on this already 6
looks the most natural but again
hurry up, maxim has no
grounds he has an hour to go according to
added but this is the last one on occasion
solution
good, yes, and here again it is not clear
will most likely remain
this video is
select 6 6 cm in the park when we leave for me
with a score of 66 to a reminder to that here
played
actually today 2 classic a
tomorrow there will be a series of which there are 2 fast
and four fighters and everywhere different
number of points, i.e. 6 points per
each classical game he is 42
the size is not rapid and further is quite
quite cheerful and although five plus five plus
three is too slow motion lasts i'm over
such yes but constantly to everyone else that
it happens anyway pretty
quite vigorous control when it comes
actually blitz it will come because
repeat again even if someone
win micro piss rapids party all
will still be played it's not a tie-break
how would separate this total tie break 6
par toby hall me yes that's when it comes
be I think that we are the first time for our
broadcast will be taken out
on yourself exactly on one party
since jumping between two parties
blitz usually turns out to be practically
impossible in rapida still still
we will tell you about water
ask if he will add it but time is not
here now time has been added to Lebanon
you can increment 1:47 from 0 to
quickly plays this game and still
we have certain doubts
whether somewhere levon
here in that very cold refrigerator
graduation as soon as it turned on
blackboard
yes, because it seems not not the maximum
chance survived
so by yes yes perhaps peter you are right
that this will be the last hitch
she looks big
last big decision regarding
how to draw up out probably
I would venture to suggest that the pain is greater than 1
way
probably black to achieve a draw
already 6 looks very cultured days
given and do not yawn as they say hard
I don't see the figure one move at all
one problem because under the king
what is our ability exactly
just not hotpot already have to go
back and again the philidor's club proper
hello can i give you pawn a6
to complete the picture for
more illustrative sti of how much
it is a beat and a draw yes therefore it is necessary
go again already and six again check
forces the king to move e7 and then I think
that's pretty simple nothing is done and
move the king 7, too, she does not see
no reason not to go h4 after that
even when it becomes difficult, yes, for whites
white people don't have enough time
to create some problems
and why do you suspect that you can one
a pawn as much as losing our 4 which is there with
second enough when loose can
enough of this one which costs 6 but not
again there is no reason to be black
check this question as they are so
people wit chat thats in every possible way
you will see a productive game in the classics
the dream of my childhood what is london like
just about london as a place of power it is
here is the place of no man's strength of the classic
perhaps yes, because 2
extremely interesting events in
classics in a row we observe in which
this is how much married
alexa's finances under 16 draw
16 in a row we have that place
incorrectly selected panda conservatory
guilty yes what else can be to blame
conservatives understandable even 6
property plays he cool move
this is exactly what she is judging by the speed with
which is made under the rook of the series i 8 check
whether he is not even going to check
Yes, you can think that it's just eternal
mine king and all rook 7 whom g8 him
he understood almost everything
wait what is he actually given
analogues of a7 i and queens 6 are not
loses up to somewhere way out ahead
probably the dinner version, but why shouldn't she
need such a boom lay down to pretend that
there is some difference where the role will go
previous king h7 no error saying
such a move turned out to be impossible to make a frame
yes, that is, it seems humanly and
captures from the king all me not really
looking at alodi asia nissan
again most likely king f8
absolutely no mistake pain just born
stronger than
queens 8 is probably just more accurate at all
there may already be enough positions or expensive
it will not be possible to get the same position
well, you are 8 nevertheless tougher with
point of view of what we already had
well, here it is
we are asked tomorrow two parties in
rapida or else and blitz no tomorrow everything
all fast disciplines in one day then
there are two rapido 25 plus 10 yes that is
it will take an hour and a half probably each
party and then four more joked
against forest park much depends on
how many breaks will there be between
what is the length of the break between
Yes, not our essential ones, but breaks
Yes, we will probably take players tomorrow
just one break between
rapid pace and well, if suddenly the organizers do not
decide let's say hang half an hour
break numbers with pins that are easy
we will fill with chatter chatter us
Are we afraid of the chatter given here
they can see there that the lemon is not quite
satisfied because somewhere around 25
it seemed that
I remember in our chat someone said that
Black's percentage chances are still in this
batches up to 25 percent I was generally like
I would tacitly agree with this assessment
kalasha white huge knocking down a desk
yes, that's it, all the factors yes there in
repo time pressure was incredible
there are only heavy objects, spring term
position and here we are watching us
show that
Score Walker Should Show Score 6 As
times the chat asks how many points for
victory in rapid chess how much in blitz in rapid
4 blitz 2 yes none
4 is being played, well, that's what
need for the same yes for believe or
get exactly as much
playing out ask by let's try
then figure out that is, victories and two
wins in two wins in rapida someone u
someone will win a520 lower on a draw in
match yes after that you will need to do
one draw in blitz in order to
secure your victory right once again
accurately cross-checking up to 5 holding in
gaining can only still number
netting to win the match
need 15 yes that is if break if
break wrapped help essentially
ended although of course it's still not enough
what happens
face but in fact ends what you can
tell us about today
today was good one party from
two parties still on my mind
it was very interesting despite the fact that
a lot of materials as per
commemorate their descendants 13 moves half
material left the board but nevertheless
very thin spire which maxim
defended by taking a heavy courageous
the decision to give up a pawn in a shallow one in which
he hasn't been in any danger yet.
after that it's all the same from him
quite a bit of precision is required
but then he
made no mistakes and
we can say that levon say 30
days on the move could think about the entrance
king g1 which is the most natural in
the party naturally wants a king
activate but maybe just
this semi-tempe was not enough for him
subsequently to have more
So what can be said about these
endless seemingly endless
draws yeah well evolved
modern chess and where am I
less wide foothold is played
actually he is again from four
draws made in this tournament so far
not only party nakamura zhurin a little
then we can set it as such a modern
grandmaster sky draw came out in trendy
options
Russian almost in which another smashed
they couldn't, well, they didn't put me there
especially tried to greet questions
a little strange the other three were
extremely interesting and
yes, it all ended in a draw, but again
but if you complain about such a beggar there
you need to look probably greatly increased
protection technology has increased and, in principle,
it is clear that
in the competitions they play
chess players of this level among themselves whose
is the favorite but again tomorrow
someday all the beggars will not be all tomorrow
beggars yes and this draw I honestly say
I do not think that someone can and and put
make claims against him
really that is got one
got an edge rank
interesting opening idea actually and
succeeded before the second succeeded collecting so
to say the will in a fist to fight back by showing
some showing a whale is enough
interesting solution thanks again everyone
who watched this broadcast of sleep and supported
asked us questions in the chat in principle that
something told us and I think that those who
was with us yesterday and today definitely
should be with us tomorrow because
tomorrow we hope for growth
audience tomorrow blitz and fast it all
there will definitely be results
mistakes will
flickering rub in general come we
we hope we can tell you about it
adequately tell therefore again
thank you all and see you tomorrow at the same
time
broadcast will start at ten to five in Moscow
ten minutes to eight in the morning at 8 am petra
[music]